[musique]
pour une innogation. Bonjour.
Bon, pardon. Bonjour Jeancha.
Nous vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Syerview.
Nous sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succintement ?
Alors, je m'appelle Bruno Got. Je suis
né le 14 décembre 1958 à Saint-Étienne
d'un père maçon italien d'une mère
papetière et euh je gagne ma vie comme
je l'ai déjà dit depuis 45 ans comme
auteur, c'est-à-dire sans rien faire
d'autre qu'auteur. Voilà,
on vous reçoit aujourd'hui parce que
votre précédente vidéo [rires]
a sauté pendant à peu près 6 à 8 mois.
Oui,
elle a un bug de YouTube. Et puis vous,
tu m'avais fait remarquer
que tu voulais revenir après ton million
et
Ah non non, c'est pas moi qui l'ai fait
remarquer.
C'est qui ?
Ben je je crois que que c'est vous, mon
cher ami.
En fait, j'ai vu un tweet
où tu étais en train d'essayer de
booster la vidéo de je sais pas qui qui
avait fait 800000.
Voilà, en disant après le million, je le
réinvite. Et j'ai juste dit c'est des
conneries. Moi, j'ai fait 1lion3, il m'a
jamais réinvité et dans les 10 secondes,
j'avais un message, "Tu viens quand tu
veux." Et j'ai dit "Bah quand tu veux et
tu m'as trouvé une date. Me voilà." Par
contre, on va parler de quoi ?
Alors, on va parler de l'humour est-il
toujours méchant ? Qu'est-ce que
Qu'est-ce que ça vous fait
ça te fait penser à quoi ?
Oh non, tu balances. Euh,
j'ai alors pour la pour ta communauté,
je suis un autodidacte complet. J'ai
arrêté l'école à 15 ans pour
incompatibilité caractérielle avec le
système éducatif. J'arrivais pas euh
parce que me faire rentrer dans la tête
tout le programme et rien que le
programme et c'est ça le programme, j'y
arrivais pas. Moi, j'avais besoin qu'on
m'explique. Donc on m'a dit très
gentiment et ben tu dégages vie active.
Et donc j'ai jamais fait d'études et
j'ai fini par gagner ma vie à partir de
l'âge de 18 ans à peu près vers 17 18
ans en écrivant.
Et j'ai très très bien gagné ma vie en
écrivant.
Combien ? Je l'ai déjà dit, quand
j'étais au guignol, je gagnais euh euh
35000 balles par mois à peu près. Et euh
et après un peu moins avec quand j'étais
à la fiction et puis maintenant je suis
chômeur. Alors je suis au taquet de ce
qu'on donne au chômage mais c'est parce
que j'ai cotisé au chômage pendant euh
25 ou 30 ans. Donc aujourd'hui que j'ai
cet accident de la vie et ben le la
communauté
m'empêche de tomber de 10 à 0. Je je
vais je tombe par palier et comme j'en
avais mis un petit peu de côté, l'un
dans l'autre, on finit par vivre. Et
donc quand je me suis retrouvé chômeur
en 2017, euh bah qu'est-ce que je vais
[__] de ma vie ?
et j'ai commencé à écrire un mémoire
pour faire un master 2 de littérature et
des métiers de l'écriture.
Et donc, j'ai fait ça dans l'idée de
faire après ça un doctorat, c'est-à-dire
écrire une thèse.
de mec quand même une thèse sur l'humour
parce que j'ai un petit problème avec
Jean Kelvic, Berkson et tout ça qui
parle du rire et de la et de l'humour,
enfin de la rigolade
parce qu'il trouve
il trouve dans le fond que l'humour
méchant c'est pas bien. Alors que moi,
je suis le fils putatif de Choron et de
Cavana. Et Cavana disait "L'humour,
c'est toujours un coup de point dans la
gueule. Il y a pas de il y a pas de loi
dans l'humour. Ni ton père, ni la choa,
ni les enfants, ni rien, ni l'écologie,
rien n'est sacré. On peut taper sur
tout." Et donc les gens disent "Si tu
fais ça, tu es méchant.
Et l'humour
est peut-être dangereux."
Hm. est peut-être dangereux,
peut-être dangereux, j'en sais rien.
Mais il faut que après on parlera du
cadre si tu veux dans lequel l'humour
s'exprime et j'ai conscience que parler
de l'humour au lieu d'en faire, il y a
rien de plus ridicule. Donc écrire une
thèse sur l'humour, c'est se frotter à
Berkson. Donc là carrément, je prends un
risque monumental mais je me dis que
l'humour est finalement toujours méchant
parce qu'il y a toujours quelqu'un ou
une institution ou quelque chose qui est
blessé par quelqu'un qui se moque. Et
généralement l'humour c'est une réaction
contre quelque chose. Et si on me dit il
y a plein de choses qui sont drôles mais
qui sont pas méchantes, je dis alors
c'est pas de l'humour, c'est autre
chose. C'est de la poésie.
Euh c'est euh euh
de la gentillesse en complicité avec
quelqu'un que tu connais bien. Mais
quand tu fais de l'humour et que tu
décides de communiquer à quelqu'un, les
motivations qui te font faire l'humour
et la façon dont tu l'abordes finit
toujours par blesser quelqu'un, même un
tout petit peu. Après, il y a des
règles.
Moi, il y a une règle en tout cas,
j'ai toujours dit que c une règle de
seigneur
qui ne se transmet que de seigneur
d'humour à seigneur d'humour. C'est que
c'est toujours le faible contre le fort.
C'est tu peux te moquer d'un
d'un écolo en en Birkenstock, tu vois,
qui fait qui élève des poules ou des des
ou des avocats dans le dans les Sévenes,
mais c'est pas la priorité. Tu peux te
[__] de sa gueule bien évidemment,
mais la priorité c'est de se moquer des
gens qui détruisent la planète, pas de
l'écolo qui fait tout pour ne pas la
détruire, même s'il est ridicule. Après,
c'est un problème de curseur. Quand les
gens ne tapent que sur les colos et pas
sur les raisons qui l'ont fait de venir
ce qu'il est, j'ai un problème. Et les
seigneurs ne font pas ça. Les seigneurs
de l'humour tapent sur le plus fort,
monsieur. Voilà, c'est et donc je me dis
tiens, je vais je vais écrire là-dessus.
Ça t'est venu comme ça ? C'estàdire,
c'est-à-dire que
l'histoire est longue.
Allez, on a du temps.
Non, non, mais l'histoire c'est que je
donne parfois des cours et je vais à la
rencontre d'étudiants dans des
universités,
des écoles pour parler de mon
expérience. Et je donne aussi des C'est
pas vraiment des cours, c'est des je
fais des classes sur comment on raconte
une histoire. tu sais les constructions.
Euh il y a des gens qui ont fait ça très
bien dans tout un tas de bouquins que
j'ai lu et euh dont deux qui sont
extraordinaire pour ceux qui écrivent
des scénares, c'est euh Robert Mcky et
John Trouby. C'est deux qui ont écrit,
il y en a un, le premier bouquin de Maki
s'appelle Story. C'est le comment on
écrit un scénar en trois actes. et John
Truby a pris la succession un peu de MI
parce que les séries, il s'est aperçu
que c'était un peu plus complexe que les
trois actes de la de la comédie ou de la
la tragédie grecque. Et il a inventé un
truc, enfin inventé, répertorié un truc
qui s'appelle les 22 Steps. Il y a 22
étapes pour raconter une histoire. Alors
évidemment, je dis aux étudiants, lisez
ces bouquins et après si vous avez des
questions parce queil y a quelque chose
qui vous gêne, je vous et donc en allant
dans ces université à chaque fois je
commence en leur disant la seule chose
que ma génération peut dire à la vôtre
c'est pardon. On vous a mis on vous a
laissé un monde mais alors il est
pourri. Nous on a kiffé notre race.
On a baisé sans capote, on a vécu la
libération sexuelle, le plein emploi,
euh enfin toutes les libertés possible
et imaginable et puis euh tout est parti
en sucette à un moment et puis les
maladies sont arrivées, le chômage est
arrivé, les ordinateurs et les machines
ont commencé à à virer les gens qui
avaient pas des spécialités sur le côté.
Il y avait plus en plus de gens, un vrai
bordel. Et maintenant vous vous êtes des
jeunes qui essayez vous essayez de
courir après un monde fun amusant
qui n'existe pas. On vous a légué un
truc pourri donc pardon.
Est-ce que tu as entendu parler de la de
la polémique avec Papa Sito ?
Oui, oui, le truc euh c'est le euh c'est
celui qui flingue des gens de gauche.
Euh faut qu' qui explique comment on
achète une arme euh pour flinguer des
gens de gauche. Euh c'est ça en gros euh
est-ce que ils sont euh étanches ? En
gros, est-ce qu'ils sont étanches aux
balles ? J'ai pas regardé.
Est-ce que Est-ce que le gauchiste, sous
forme de question, est-ce que le
gauchiste arrête les balles ? C'est c
C'est ça le truc, c'est est-ce que le
gauchisme arrête les balles ? Je vais te
montrer un extrait d'une vidéo qui dure
1 minute 58 qu'on a trouvé sur Twitter
d'une vidéo qui a été tournée sur une
chaîne YouTube de valeur actuelle.
Oui, c'est des très très bon journal de
droite
très traditionnel. Très traditionnel.
On regarde ça ensemble.
Ouais.
Et et c tu étais pas prévenu. C'était
pas prévu. Et ensuite, je voudrais que
tu essayes d'analyser ce que le mec
raconte. Waouh
!
Alors, est-ce que vous êtes prêt à la
technique 3 ? Quoi ? On est les mecs qui
produisent de l'humour quoi ? On est les
mecs qui produisent de l'humour, on est
ceux qui bousculent les choses. Et les
mêmes 68 qui nous disaient il faut
déconstruire il y a je sais pas combien
de temps, ce sont les mêmes qui nous
disent aujourd'hui oh oui, Faustère, ça
allit trop loin. Mais ils ont fait 10
fois pire dans leur journaux. Il faudra
parler des unees de Charlie Hebdo. Le
Coran, c'est de la merde. Ça n'arrête
pas les balles.
Moi ma vidéo, elle s'appelle le
gauchisme n'arrête pas les Est-ce que le
gauchisme est-il parallellement ? Je
pose la question au moins eux ils
avaient dit que le Coran c'était de la
merde parce ça n'arrêtait pas les
balles. Donc la gauche a le droit de
dire que le Coran c'est de la merde. Et
moi j'ai pas le droit de demander si la
gauche le gauchis par balle. Il y a un
deux poids de mesure. Comment ça se fait
que moi il y a des conférences de presse
parce que j'ai fait une vidéo. Comment
ça se fait que monsieur Daniel Commandit
qui a déclaré à la télé que c'était
stylé quand tuas un gamin qui vient te
palucher la courge dans le pantalon et
que tout le monde est là autour, il
rigole et c'est normal. C'est fini les
boomers. Le règne là de tout ce que vous
voulez. Bon la pédophile autorisé. C'est
fini ça. C'est fini. C'est fini. Vous
avez trop fait de saloperie pour qu'on
se gêne et pour qu'on déconstruise pas
le monde que vous avez déconstruit.
Parce que c'est ça qu'ils ont fait.
C'est ça les 68. Ils ont détruit la
France. Ils ont installé un système qui
ne marche pas et ils nous en veulent de
venir détruire ça. Et ben, c'est le
retour de bâton. Voilà, c'est biblique.
S'ils avaient lu la Bible, au lieu de
dire les les conneries qu' a écrit Mao
ou Trotski qui a pris une pioche dans la
FIF, d'ailleurs, tu vois, euh Dieu, il a
pas pris une pioche dans la FIF, tu
vois. S'ils avaient lu la Bible, ils
auraient vu que il y a toujours un
retour de bâton. Tu vois, je veux dire,
il y a toujours un retour de bâton. Tu
peux pas déconstruire toutes les règles,
toute la hiérarchie. Dire "Il y a plus
de règles, c'est bon notre pays c'est
une chatte four est là", tu vois. Et
tout d'un coup, tu as un mec qui déboule
et il te fait la même chose et là ils
comprennent pas. Mais qu'est-ce qui se
passe ? Euh, qu'est-ce qui se passe là
gauche ? Je croyais que c'était la
déconstruction, la déconnade à Rakiri,
Charlie Hebo, Canal Plus, on se fout de
la gueule de la classe moyenne.
Rappelez-vous les des chiens.
Rappelez-vous quotidien qui se moquait
d'un homme qui un paysan là qu'ils
avaient filmé chez lui. Il était en slip
le mec. Ils ont détruit sa vie. Un
paysan, le mec qui cultive le soja qui
se mett dans le corps pour atteindre
leurs 60 kg là il y en a marre de cette
dictature. Je me coucherai pas. Je me
coucherai pas.
Alors ben quand je vous dis qu'on vous a
laissé un monde de merde non, c'est un
renversement de valeur et c'est ce qu'il
dit. C'est c'est entendable. Je peux je
peux entendre. Euh vous avez fait ça,
vous vous êtes moqué et puis nous on
fait pareil. Sauf que euh la moquerie
entre [grognement] guillemets de gauche,
elle te donne les congés payés. Elle te
donne la sécurité sociale et la moquerie
parce que ça c'est déjà arrivé dans les
années 20 30 ce type de moquerie. Le
juif sousse, comment les reconnaître ?
C'est eux qui font la les méchants.
C'est stigmatiser quelqu'un. Ça a déjà
existé. Ça ça amène la choa, ça amène
une guerre mondiale et des millions de
morts. Voilà, la seule différence, elle
est là. C'est ce que je te disais sur
euh euh c'est un renversement de valeur
euh et tu te sers. C'est de l'quido
mental qui fait "Ah, vous l'avez fait,
j'ai le droit de le faire et vous n'avez
pas le droit de critiquer." Sauf que les
gens qui le faisaient, je veux pas
parler que de l'image, mais regarde
Cabu, le grand Duduche, le mec, il a tu
le sens qu'il est inoffensif et il se
moque de qui ? De l'armée, il se moque
des rigidités de la vie et il a un grand
manteau. Tu sens pas qu'il va te faire
du mal ?
habillé comme il est, tu le croises dans
une rue, tu sens qu'il peut te tuer. Tu
sens qu'il peut te faire du mal ce mec
là. Et il fait peur. Et il fait exprès
de faire peur. Bon, moi il me fait pas
peur, je le prends quand il veut, c'est
aucun problème. Mais il la volonté c'est
de te faire peur. Ça a déjà existé dans
les années 30. Ça existait les gens
comme lui qui disaient "On a assez
rigolé, on a assez les années folles,
c'est fini maintenant terminé."
On vous a vraiment laissé un monde de
merde avec des gens comme ça dedans. Je
suis désolé.
Est-ce que Est-ce que tu peux comprendre
qu'est-ce qui pousse à en arriver
jusqu'à ces extrêmes là ? Est-ce que
c'est parce que l'humour de gauche,
l'humour est toujours de gauche,
c'est pas vrai.
L'humour est toujours de gauche parce
que l'humour
c'est euh le faible qui veut une
condition meilleure et qui attaque le
méchant qui l'opprime.
Il y a pas il y a pas des faibles de
droite ? Non, ça peut pas être de
droite. Pour moi, l'humour peut pas être
de droite puisque c'est le faible,
l'opprimé, celui qui prend dans la
gueule qui doit se moquer de celui qui
l'opprime. Dès que l'opprimé ou
l'opprimeur, si l'opprimeur tape sur
l'opprimé, c'est pas de l'humour.
Donc, j'en arrive à ma question qui est
exactement ça. Est-ce que l'humour de
gauche qui a opprimé ce qui est censé
être l'ultra droite depuis des
décennies,
ça les a poussé à réagir comme ça ?
Est-ce que c'est pas un un effet
papillon ? C'est-à-dire c'est bien gavé
pendant des décennies sur leur tête.
Alors c'était facile
mais c'est pas sur leur tête.
Attends attends attends. C'est c'était
c'est est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est
pas ça qui a amené des réactions
pareilles ? C'est-à-dire à force de les
charier, à force de se [__] de leur
gueule à force en anglais on dit bullid.
Comment tu dis en français ce euh les
harceler
h
à force de les de les
mettre en boîte, est-ce que ça n'a pas
fait des démons ? Est-ce que est-ce que
l'humour de gauche qui ne s'est jamais
arrêté sur leur tête
et qui continue d'ailleurs s'arrête pas,
est-ce que ça ne génère pas des démons ?
Des démons ?
Oui.
Je Non, c'est c'est lui tuappelle enfin
c'est lui que t'appelle démon mais c'est
pas un démon. C'est juste un me C'est
juste un mec qui a trouvé le moyen
d'exister à travers quel mot je
l'appelle pas des mots. Est-ce que c'est
pas une réaction épidermique de
l'extrême droite qui à force de s'être
fait de s'être
retrouvé en boîte par les médias de
gauche, l'humour de gauche et tout et
tout qui va bien avec, est-ce que ça n'a
pas généré une frustration qui les a
amené à réagir comme ça ? Mais ils
étaient frustrés depuis très longtemps.
Moi ça me gêne pas que ces gens soient
frustrés quand tu as peur euh quand tu
as peur des Arabes, quand tu as peur des
Noirs, quand tu as peur de du désordre,
quand tu as peur de trop de liberté,
parce qu'il y a plein de gens qui font
plein de choses autour de toi et que toi
tu es pas capable de les faire. Oui, ça
fait peur. Mais ils ont toujours été
trouillards ces gens. C'est des
trouillards en fait. Ils ont peur. Ils
ont besoin d'armes, de force, de faire
de la muscu pour pouvoir aller défier je
ne sais qui. C'est que tu vas pas aller
défier Guillaume Meuris que j'aime bien
et il est comme ça, tu vois. Tu mets lui
en face qui qui fait peur à l'autre.
Franchement et euh cette volonté de
faire c'est pas que de la frustration.
C'est parce qu'il y a la possibilité
aujourd'hui de le faire.
Quand les médias deviennent tous de
droite en gros parce qu'ils ont été
achetés par des gens qui préfèrent la
droite, au début ils sont libéraux
économiquement puis il faut de l'ordre
puis ils acceptent dans leurs médias que
puisqu'il faut de l'ordre et ben on va
parler de ça. On va parler de
l'insécurité. Il y a de l'insécurité
évidemment qu'il y a de l'insécurité. On
le voit. Battons-nous contre
l'insécurité. Mais si tu stigmatises des
gens, tu penses quoi ? Surtout pour ce
qui concerne l'islam, il y en a 7
millions en France. Il y en a combien
qui sont entre guillemets terroristes ?
Je me fais l'avocat du diable. D'accord.
B vas-y. De toute façon, tu adores faire
ça.
Ouais. Complotiste.
Toujours toujours penser contre ses ses
propres idées.
Mais tu crois qu'on faisait quoi ? Moi,
j'ai fait les guignoles pendant 16
piges. Tous les matins, on s'est demandé
ce qu'on faisait. Tous les matins, on
s'est dit est-ce que ça on peut le dire
? Est-ce que ça a une incidence sur la
communauté, sur les communautés qui nous
regardent ? Nous, quand il y a eu les
caricatures de Charlie Hebdo, à Char, je
crois que je l'ai raconté la dernière
fois cette histoire, non ? Je me semble
que je l'ai raconté. Quand il y a eu
l'histoire des caricatures de Charlie
HBDO, ça part d'un journal danois.
Ça commence avec un journal danois qui
dit qui lance un appel au nom d'un
auteur dont j'ai oublié le nom qui fait
un livre pour enfants sur le Coran et il
dit "Je ne trouve pas de dessinateur
parce que les gens ont peur de dessiner
Allah et dessiner sur le Coran."
Et le journal danois, donc tu vois c'est
quand même ténu au départ, le journal
danois lance un concours de caricatures
qui ne sont pas très très bonnes.
Franchement, elles sont pas terribles.
On aurait dû interroger la qualité des
dessins, mais on l'a pas fait à l'époque
et on continue à pas le faire. Mais on
aurait dû interroger la qualité des
dessins. On le fait pas. Là, ça se part
en vrille dans tous les sens. On
rappelle des ambassadeurs, les pays
musulmans brûlent des drapeaux. C'est un
merdier monumental tout ça parce que un
dessinateur finalement a dit "Oh ben,
ils veulent pas dessiner. Ils ont peur
des musulmans parce que il y a eu des
attentats ou je sais pas quoi. Il y en a
eu un qui est s'est fait tuer." Bon
effectivement, il y a quelqu'un qui
s'est fait tuer, c'est grave. Il faut
arrêter les terroristes, faut les mettre
en prison, les condamner sévèrement.
Mais stigmatiser toute une communauté,
ça a foutu un feu. Et nous, on s'est
retrouvé au Guignol dans l'obligation
presque de publier ces trucs là pour
dire "Nous sommes libres. Regardez à
quel point on est libre, on le fait
quand même. Et à un moment, on a
réfléchi, on s'est posé 2 minutes, on a
dit ça part d'où le journal, le
dessinateur, le machin ? OK, est-ce que
ça mérite autant ?
Et on a répondu non parce qu'il y a des
gens qui nous regardent qui ont été
franchement blessés par ces caricatures
avec une bombe sur la tête. OK, ils ont
été blessés. Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? On
leur crache à la gueule en leur disant
"Vous avez été blessé ?" Et ben, on s'en
fout. où on dit "OK, c'est cette
caricature qui te pose un problème, OK,
on va pas la montrer et on va t'en
montrer une autre." Et on a sorti notre
Allah à nous avec deux autres dieux qui
disaient en fait pourquoi on n pas le
droit pourquoi le l'islam esticonique ?
Pourquoi on n pas le droit de mettre la
la l'image de Allah ? Ben on a dit c'est
juste parce qu'il perd ses cheveux le
mec il est moche comme un cul. On dira
un bouddhiste. C'est pour ça qu' Et on a
jamais eu d'emmerdement. Pourtant, on a
dit qu'il était moche comme un cul,
qu'il était bouddhiste et on l'a montré.
Ils nous ont pas emmerdé. C'est juste
une caricature qui les embêtait. Est-ce
que appuyer toujours là où ça fait mal
sur les mêmes,
c'est de l'humour ?
Moi, je crois que non. Je crois que
quand tu sais que tu vas faire plus de
mal qu'apporter de bien, alors il faut
que tu arrêtes. Et nous, on a arrêté. Ça
veut pas dire qu'on s'est pas moqué de
l'islam. On s'est moqué des de la
religion en général. Moi je suis pas
religieux. Donc tu imagines bien quand
on me dit euh il y a des mecs qui se
tapent la tête sur un sur un mur d'un
temple en ruine ou d'autres gens qui
prient en direction d'un un bâtiment
administratif saoudien, tu vois, je m'en
fous. Est-ce que c'est pas la même avec
la
le courant câateau on va dire de droite
h
que la gauche a stigmatiser avec des
motsqueries toujours appuyés toujours au
même endroit tout le temps. Tout le
temps, tout le temps.
Est-ce qu'il faut arrêter ou est-ce
qu'il faut continuer ?
Il faut toujours se moquer de la
religion et du rite religieux.
Faut s'en remoquer quand on est euh
quand on fait de l'humour, quand on veut
se marrer, il y a quand même la religion
c'est une source inépuisable de bêtises.
Quand même on sait que l'univers
visible, c'est 83 milliards d'années
lumière. Et on vient nous expliquer que
la petite planète comme ça, elle a été
créée par Dieu et qu'il a creusé le
grand canyon aussi et que c'est lui qui
a fait quoi ? Xantia diesel les
ornitorinqu faut arrê
h
François Hollande
François Hollande il a créé François
Hollande tu vois donc il a fait il a pas
fait que des trucs bien tu vois donc
ouais non j'arrive pas à
tu vois que l'humour peut être de droite
h
pourquoi
François Hollande
François Hollande il est de gauche ou il
est de droite
Hollande il est de gauche bah tu vois
j'apprends des trucs en venant ici mo
j'apprends des trucs non mais c'est bien
tu vois c'est on apprend
revenon revenon
je te rappelle au départ on On a
commencé sur l'idée que j'avais écrit un
mémoire que je défondais, que je
soutenais le 18 de ce mois
dans mes pensées. Donc l'humour est-il
toujours méchant ?
Ouais.
Et s'il n'est pas méchant, est-ce de
l'humour ?
C'est à ça que je vais essayer de
répondre. C'est à c'est pour ça que je
vais devenir doctorant et que je vais
essayer de de travailler sur sur cet
humour et travailler aussi sur sur ce
monsieur qu'on a vu là qui a l'air un
peu costaud et qui parle d'humour. Et
oui, lui il pense qu'il fait rire et il
fait rire probablement une communauté
qui est pas la même. Donc quand l'humour
est clivant à ce point-là, est-ce que
c'est de l'humour ? C'est des c'est des
vraies interrogations ?
Et ceux qui se cachent derrière l'humour
pour faire passer des slogans
politiques,
est-ce que c'est quoi ?
Ben les caricatures.
Est-ce que l'humour de gauche, c'est des
gens qui se cachent derrière l'humour
pour faire passer des slogans politiques
?
Je me fais encore l'avocat du diable.
Non non, mais c'est tu as raison en
fait. Euh oui, ça peut arriver mais si
c'est ça, ça peut pas durer très
longtemps parce que ça se voit et les
gens arrêtent de rire. Euh quand ça se
voit trop, ça fonctionne pas. À un
moment, quelqu'un qui fait de l'humour
en étant un peu militant, il veut
changer le monde pour que ça aille
mieux. C'est-à-dire en ce qui me
concerne pour qu'on trouve une harmonie
entre le mec qu'on vient de voir qui qui
est pas ma tasse de thé et je dois vivre
avec lui quand même. On partage le même
monde donc il faut qu'on vive ensemble.
Comment on fait pour réussir à trouver
une harmonie qui fait que le monde est
plus ou moins en équilibre ? Les raisons
de déséquilibre et de désharmonie sont
tellement grandes que c'est peut-être
pas la peine de passer du temps à
creuser les faussé.
Est-ce que Est-ce que la bienveillance
la bienveillance est-ce que c'est une
piste dans l'humour ?
Oui, l'humour Ouais, ça doit être
bienveillant.
Tu aurais un exemple.
Bah par exemple, j'ai arrêté les
Guignoles en 2007 et je me suis amusé
pendant 15 ans avec Chirak et il y avait
une certaine bienveillance avec Chirak.
Quand Sarkozi
est devenu président ou allait devenir
président, on savait que ça serait lui.
Euh, j'ai dit "J'arrête parce que je ne
l'aime pas." C'est quelqu'un que j'aime
pas ni physiquement, ni dans ce qui
représente, ni dans sa façon d'être.
C'est c'est quelqu'un voilà, j'aime pas.
Alors ça vient de mon enfance. Les gens
comme lui, je pouvais pas les blairer
mais qui la ramène tout le temps. J'aime
pas. Et je me suis dit et je l'ai dit
aux autres et on se l'ai dit tous
ensemble, j'ai dit moi je ne pourrais
pas faire d'humour longuement,
durablement avec Sarkozy parce que tu
fais rien de bien quand tu es dans la
méchanceté.
Ça va se voir, on va ça va être haineux
et ça va pas être intéressant. Donc vous
vous en foutez complètement, faites-le
mais moi je peux plus le faire.
Qui est-ce qui était responsable des
sketchs avec les sacs à mains de Bernadé
Chirac ?
quand elle prenait son sac à main. Ouis.
Ouais.
Je crois que c'est tu m'en veux pas
Bebeu mais je crois que c'est toi.
C'est Mais j'ai raconté déjà l'histoire,
je te la refais si tu veux en cours.
C'est un
le sketch de Bernadette. C'est un sketch
raté poubelle.
L'idée de départ je crois que c'est
Benoît qui a eu l'idée, c'est de montrer
Bernadette Siracelle avait toujours son
sac à main. se balada tout le temps avec
un sac et c'est de dire de montrer
Bernadet Chirac chez elle toute seule
quand Chirac s'en va, elle regarde comme
ça, elle prend une cassette comme à
l'époque on prenait des cassettes. Vous
voyez ce que c'est les cassettes ? La
communauté et place de truc enfin bon.
et elle elle s'approchait d'un d'un
magnétoscope, elle mettait la cassette
dans le magnétoscope, elle se mettait
comme ça et elle regardait des vidéos de
téléachat de sac à main comme si c'était
un porno. Elle faisait
bon, c'était c'était que ça au départ.
Et le jeudi, on avait visionnage des
sketchs qu'on avait demandé et on
regarde le sketch et le réalisateur nous
dit "J'ai essayé, ça marche pas votre
truc c'était voilà, c'était pas une
bonne idée." Ah, je dis "Ah merde, on
peut voir donc on regarde le truc.
Ouais, effectivement ça marche pas." Il
dit "Par contre, on a fait une version à
nous si tu veux." Ouais, vas-y. Et là,
c'est la version qu'on a diffusé crypté.
C'estàd que ça part enville, elle se
elle se met la main dans le sac à main.
Enfin, c'est porn du porno allemand.
Voilà.
Et donc on dit "OK, on s'est bien amusé
poubelle."
Le temps passe, les mois passent et à
l'époque je faisait l'ouverture de nulle
part ailleurs, c'est les petits éditaux.
Et donc je vais à j'allais vers 16h30
écrire l'éditao, voir ce qu'avait fait
les auteurs. J'écrivais l'édito et je
revenais à 17h30 ou 18h euh pour faire
la lecture du JT. Et eux pendant ce
temps-là, ils choisissaient le sketch
qu'on allait diffuser. Et c'était la
journée de la femme.
Le jour de la journée de la femme, ils
mettent le sac à main de Bernadette.
Et j'arrive, je dis "Non, non, les mecs,
vous êtes tarés." Non, non. Pourquoi
vous avez fait ? Vous êtes fou. Ils me
disent "Mais non, mais c'est on a trouvé
l'idée. Comment ça on a trouvé l'idée ?"
Et ben on a trouvé en fait on verra pas,
on va crypter. Et moi, je suis tellement
dans autre choses que je dis pas non. En
fait, je dis "Ouais, OK."
flouté
h
flouteré
oui flitter enf crypter l'image comme le
cryptage des films porno canal à
l'époque et je dis bah allez-y ouais ok
ok c'est si on voit pas c'est et puis je
réfléchis pas en fait donc je je vais
faire mon truc tout ça et en remontant
de du studio dans mon bureau, je remonte
avant que les guignoles commencent.
J'allais rater les guignoles en fait et
j'entends dans les bureaux les gens qui
hurlent je dis je rentre dans un bureau
et qu'est-ce qu'il y a ? Oh là là, le
sac à main. Oh [__] c'est drôle et
tout ça.
Je regarde le truc en fait, le cryptage
décuple l'idée du porno.
Au lieu de l'atténuer, ça ça a multiplié
par 100. Tout le monde a compris ce
qu'elle faisait derrière le crypta. J'en
voyais pas mais tout le monde a compris.
Et là [__]
donc de greffe il me dit ouais bien le
sac à moi bien
le truc passe tranquille se passe rien.
Le dimanche arrive, semaine des
guignoles
et
avant la semaine des guignoles, il y
avait une émission qui s'appelait c'est
pas le vinh, qui était présenté par
Thiir
et à l'intérieur de cette émission, il y
a une émission qui s'appelle le zapping
en qui s'appelait le zapping
extraordinaire. Tu une magnifique
magnifique parler des superpositions de
la télévision juste en image. Tuas un
moment qui a disparu de la télévision,
je me demande pourquoi et
Thiir qui est donc le gendre de Chirac
qui était le mari de Claude, le le papa
de je sais plus comment il s'appelle.
Bref, et euh ils sont en famille
et Chirac dit "Et si on regardait
l'émission de Thierry ?" OK, donc ils se
mettent tous la famille ça et il regarde
et là zapping et ce con de men Patrick
Mena
sketch en entier.
Et donc tu imagines la famille Chirac
dans le canapé avec le café.
Donc Thierry après je lui ai demandé,
j'ai dit
c'est que la réaction il shira que c'est
marré.
Mais maman non maman ça l'a pas fait
rire. Donc il y a eu lettre bordel et
tout. Excusez-vous.
Et là il y a un dîner.
Je parle sous contrôle de Pierre l'escur
qui adore Sycurview. Peut-être regardera
celle-là.
On fait un on est convoqué
donc il y a Benoît de l'Épine,
Jean-François Alain et moi et en face il
y a Pierre l'Escure et Alain de Greff.
Et le truc c'est bon, vous avez fait une
connerie, il faut vous excuser. Et là il
y a Jean-François Alain qui est j'adore
quand il est comme ça. Il dit "Mais je
comprends pas Pierre pourquoi parce que
vous pouvez pas montrer la femme du
président de la République qui se
masturbe, ça se fait pas. Et Pierre elle
se masturbe pas, elle touche le bouton
d'un sac à main. Non ! Arrête de me
faire Et l'autre n'en démornait pas." Tu
vois Jean-François tonnait disant "Je ne
peux pas m'excuser parce que elle touche
son sac à main. Ça n'est pas du tout ce
que tu crois. arrêtez de nous [__] de
ma gueule et tout beb il dit ouais on
s'en fout et
tu de greff il se marrent tout le temps
il était là ouais bon la discussion elle
est lunaire he ça a aucun sens cette
discussion n'a aucun sens
et là
on se tourne vers moi qui je suis
toujours le plus raisonnable en fait et
on me dit bon qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors
je dis je veux bien écrire une lettre il
y aura pas d'excuse à l'intérieur mais
je veux bien faire une lettre à madame
Chirak en lui disant Non, oui, on a vu
que ça pouvait être choquant pour vous,
pour votre famille
et vous avez gagné le droit à la
tranquillité pendant un certain temps.
Maintenant, on vous embêtera plus
pendant un certain temps. Et
Jean-François dit "Je signerai jamais
cette lettre là. Je signerai jamais une
lettre, même s'il y a pas des Je
signerai jamais."
Donc ça la situation est un peu bloquée
et c'est Bebeu qui a trouvé Benoît de
l'épine qui trouve la solution en disant
moi je veux bien signer la lettre mais
dans le sketch il y a aussi Pierre
Belmar donc il faut envoyer aussi une
lettre la même à Pierre Belmar et donc
on a envoyé à Pierre Bellmar qui nous a
répondu je ne sais pas de quoi vous
parlez mais j'accepte vos excuses
[rires]
complètement débiles et ça aussi c'est
on appelle ça un effet strisante
aujourd'hui mais personne n'aurait rien
fait personne n'aurait rien dit madame
Chirek aurait pas réagi, ça passait prof
et perte tu vois une vidéo chasse
l'autre un chasse l'autre c'est comme ça
que ça se passe à la télé et là ça a mis
le focus dessus plein de machin l'élysée
gueule c'est tout le monde voulait voir
ce sketch et finalement tout le monde
l'a vu et 20 ans après tu m'en parles
encore.
Tu dis tu dis l'humour c'est s'attaquer
au fort.
Ouais
Bernadette
déjà femme de de Chirak. Alors, on dit
toujours que derrière chaque grand
homme, il y a une grande femme. Il a
un excellent livre là-dessus. Femme des
dictateurs de Dianne Ducret. Je vous
conseille de lire.
Tu La pauvre Bernadette, elle avait rien
demandé.
Elle faisait elle faisait ses pièces
jaunes.
Ouais.
Elle essayait de faire rattraper les
conneries. Les pièces jaunes, ça a aucun
rapport avec la politique. Le fait
qu'elle fasse les pièces jaunes pendant
les élections, juste avant une élection,
qu'elle mobilise énormément tout un
train, qu'elle emmène des gens dedans,
qu'elle fasse tous les 20 heurs, qu'elle
fasse tout un ça n'a rien à voir avec le
fait qu'elle aiderait son mari à faire
une campagne.
Entièrement raison. Et Philippe Segin
déguisé en sadomasochiste qui se
fouette. [rires]
Non mais arrête, tu me fais parler avec
des guignoles ou quoi ? Je viens
d'écrire un mémoire, bordel.
Laisse-moi y venir.
Mais ça c'est la plus grande rigolade de
notre vie. Mais qu'est-ce que
feu Philippe Seguin ?
Oui, paix à son âme et c'est quelqu'un
que j'aimais bien Seguin. Franchement,
je l'avais rencontré plusieurs fois au
Parc des Princes, on se voyait au stade,
c'est c'est un mec bien. Et
il s'était mis 4e sur une liste dans des
régionales ou des municipales où il
avait aucune chance de gagner. Il allait
au Caspib quoi il est Sadomazo ce mec
là, il va pas comment elle s'appelait ?
Roxane de Corte, la tête de liste,
illustre inconnu qu'il est resté. Enfin,
je sais pas si ça se trouve vous faites
quelque chose de très bien madame
Decorte, excusez-moi mais
et on s'est dit il est mazo et on a
commencé à rire avec ça. Le magazine
c'était quoi ?
Fouet magazine que fesse-moi avec une
pelle.com
[grognement] à un moment. Alors là, je
vais les je vais vous balancer tous les
auteurs des guignoles qui regardent
Syerview.
Euh
euh c'est pas Lionel du Temple, je crois
que c'est non si c'est Lionel. Julien
Hervé qui trouve cette phrase énorme.
Ppéd c'est vous aimez vous aimez prendre
des coups quand même là vous mettez 4è
dit ouais j'adore ça. Et à un moment il
lui dit clou-moi le gland sur le bureau
et tire-moi fort en arrière.
J'ai
passé à la télé ça ? Bah bien sûr. Et là
j'ai l'image.
Wouh ! [__] mais c'était drôle.
Qu'est-ce qu'on riait avec ça.
C'était P Vlenski avant l'heure.
Bah oui oui, c'est vrai qu'il s'était
cloué sur la place rouge lui.
[rires]
Il est il est bien lui. Il a bien pris
aussi non ? Lui il a pris une pelle
aussi. Enfin bon voilà. Mais tu me fais
parler des guignoles. C'est ça fait
vieux con mais bon j'assume d'être un
vieux con. 63 piges est droit
maintenant.
Est-ce que est-ce que le le l'humour
revendiqué de Papa Sito qui a poignardé
des gauchistes, leur tirer dans la
gueule avec
un coup de 12, est-ce que c'est de
l'humour ou c'est de la violence ou
c'est ce qui ou est-ce que c'est de
l'humour incompris ? Non, mais de son
point de vue, c'est probablement de
l'humour. C'est probablement ce que lui
fait rire. Et quand il dit euh "Est-ce
que le gauchisme est par bal ?" Je
pourrais le dire moi. C'est vrai. Est-ce
que le gauchisme est par bal ? C'est ça
peut être marrant. Après, tu
l'illustres.
Ça peut être marrant. 20 minutes, moi je
dirais que tu as fait un peu long,
papacito. Mais voilà, c'est 20 minutes,
c'est autre chose. Mais le dire comme il
le dit là, les mecs, vous nous avez vous
nous avez craché dessus tout ça,
maintenant il y a un retour de bâton. Tu
sens d'abord que c'est pas vraiment de
l'humour, ça c'est haineux. Il explique
pourquoi il fait les choses. Euh cette
haine qu'il a euh pour ceux qui se sont
moqués de lui. Il a l'air assez jeune,
je sais pas l'âge qu'il a mais
35 ans, je crois. Combien il a
35 ans.
Bon, il a 35 piges. Il a même pas
regardé les guignoles. Tu vois Canal, il
a dû regarder en en biais, il était
adolescent. Donc qu'est-ce qu'il faisait
comme qu'est-ce qui a fait que comme
ados, il s'est senti attaqué à ce
point-là ? Il avait une conscience déjà
adolescent de cette de cet humour qui
serait de gauche et qui s'en prendrait à
lui spécifiquement
quand il va se faire tatouer des croix
machin. Je sais pas c'est je sais pas ce
qu'il a dans la tête, je le connais pas
ce monsieur et je [raclement de gorge]
regarde pas ce qu'il fait parce que
franchement pourquoi j'irais m'infliger
ça ? Mais puisque tu m'interroges dessus
avec bienveillance, il a C'est haineux
ce qu'il raconte à ce que tu m'as
montré. C'est haineux. C'est on va
maintenant on va se venger. Attention,
retour de bâton. Donc il confirme le
fait qu'il veut nous tuer parce que je
me considère moi comme de gauche voire
gauchiste. Donc il il veut me tuer. Donc
s'il y a une plainte collective, je m'y
associerai parce que euh si c'est de
l'humour,
l'humour normalement c'est quand c'est
drôle, tu vois. Là c'est pas marrant.
Euh alors après dans ses vidéos que je
regarde pas, peut-être qu'il a des trucs
marrants, j'en sais rien. Et si ça fait
rire une communauté et ben euh c'est de
l'humour puisque il fait rire une
communauté.
Est-ce qu'il doit s'excuser
de quoi ?
De d'avoir blessé autant euh
Ah non non, mais c'est pas à lui de
s'excuser, lui il fait quelque chose. Il
faut qu'en face il y a une réponse. Moi
je veux pas interdire les gens quel
qu'il soit. On n'interdit pas. Il a le
droit de s'exprimer. Il a le droit de
faire ce qu'il veut.
S'il trouve
100 personnes pour le regarder, ça veut
dire que le monde ne va pas trop mal. Si
l'on trouve un million, il y a peut-être
un petit problème avec le monde. Si en
plus valeur actuelle lui fait de la pub
et lui donne la parole pour lui dire
"Alors, allez tous voir sa vidéo, c'est
qu'il y a un autre problème, c'est que
le monde dans lequel on est, donc je me
réexcuse, on vous a laissé un monde de
merde.
Le monde dans lequel on est
attes
médias. On attise
la volonté de bienveillance. On se fout
de la gueule de l'éclos. Quand je te
disais tout à l'heure, le curseur qui le
pauvre avec son Loden, il faisait pas de
mal même s'il s'en prenait à l'armée.
Toi, tu tu voyais pas ce mec-là te te
torturer.
Par contre, lui, je le je le sens bien
choper un gossiste et lui faire du mal.
Alors, peut-être que je me trompe, mais
dans son apparence en tout cas, il a la
volonté d'afficher quelque chose de très
masculiniste, de très euh je fais de la
muscu, je suis costaud, je suis si toi,
la barbe, les lunettes. Tu as vu mec, je
veux moi faut pas me faire chier.
C'est pas bienveillant
ou je me trompe ? Je suis pas là pour
donner mon
Non, non, mais je voilà, je Mais il a le
droit de s'exprimer honnêtement. Je
jamais je dirais il faut interdire
quelqu'un. Je n'aime pas qu'on interdise
quelqu'un. C'est à nous d'apporter un
matériel critique en face de ça.
Maintenant, est-ce que tu apportes un
matériel critique face à une kalashnikov
? J'en sais rien. C'est c'est compliqué,
c'est plus compliqué. Mais euh je
souhaiterais
que quand il fait euh ce ce genre de
déclaration, parce que là, il fait pas
de l'humour là, il fait c'est une
déclaration, c'est ce que je fais là. Je
fais pas de l'humour, c'est une
déclaration. Euh je souhaiterais que les
gens se disent "Tu tu parles d'humour
habillé comme ça, c'est ça ton
personnage Tu vois, j'ai jamais vu un
mec comme ça dans un dans un standup par
exemple, tu en connais ? Je vois pas un
mec qui veut fait du standup et on voit
si tu remplit les salles.
On regarde pas les standup sauf Bebar et
et le chinois.
Moi je regarde les standup américains,
je les ai regardé tous, Dev Chapelle et
tout ça.
George Carline.
Oui, bien sûr. J'ai regardé tout ça. Je
regarde ces trucs-là. Euh ils sont
offensifs mais c'est toujours
bienveillant. Il y a toujours l'idée
que euh celui qui est pauvre
par l'humour peut pendant un tout petit
moment se venger du gars qui est fort.
Celui qui est fort, c'est celui qui a
tous les moyens de la justice, d'argent,
l'armée
pour faire appliquer ce qu'il souhaite.
Le faible, lui, bah il va bosser, ferme
sa gueule, paye les impôts et puis il
rentre chez lui. Et
c'est pas ce qui se passe avec l'extrême
droite maintenant. C'est-à-dire
est-ce qu'il se est-ce qu'il se
considèrent pas comme la minorité faible
maintenant ?
Mais non, ils ont gagné. Ils sont fous.
Ils sont ils sont sur toutes les chaîne
d'info. L'extrême droite, elle est sur
toutes les chaînes d'infos.
Culturellement, j'ai perdu la bataille
culturelle. C'est c'est fini, c'est
terminé. On a perdu. Je suis dans un
pessimisme en ce moment terrible. Il
faut leur laisser le terrain.
Pourquoi ?
Hm, on peut pas. Pourquoi il faut leur
laisser le terrain ?
Parce qu'ils ont déjà gagné. Ils ont
déjà gagné
culturellement.
Toutes les chaînes d'infos, toutes
France info un peu moins mais toutes les
chaînes d'info aujourd'hui n'invitent
que des gens d'extrême droite ou de
droite.
Toujours ça c'est caricatural. Il y a
pas de droite, il y a pas de gauche. Il
y a une philosophie qui est plus
droitière qu'une philosophie de gauche.
La philosophie de gauche peut être
naïve. Bien sûr qu'elle peut être naïve.
Alors, il faut s'aimer tous les uns les
autres pendant qu'il y a des mecs en
banlieu qui vont flaquer des vieilles.
Ouais. C'est difficile mais ils le font.
Ça existe. Tu me fais des gros yeux.
Bien sûr que ça existe. Je le sais que
ça existe. Mais la réponse à ça, c'est
de mettre des flics là-bas. C'est de pas
fermer les commissariats.
C'est de mettre des gens qui vont
physiquement être là. C'estàd de la
police, des animateurs si tu veux.
Voilà. Des des gens qui vont essayer de
canaliser les gens. La police c'est pas
des animateurs.
Non mais la police c'est pas fait pour
être des animateurs. Mais ça dépend
c'est que si tu vois les mêmes flics
tous les jours et qui se balade dans la
rue qui sont intégrés dans le truc bah
quand il y en a un qui fait une
connerie, tu vas le voir, tu dis "O
viens voir làin arrête ça. Ça t'arrêtes,
tu fais plus." Et petit
tu parles du flic que tu lui demandes de
venir, c'est ça ?
H
tu parles du flic, tu lui dis "Viens,
viens parce que tu fais une connerie".
[rires]
Non mais les flics il peu ils peuvent
pas discuter.
Moi je suis il y a aussi un truc, par
exemple, on me dit euh tu es antiflic.
Non non, je suis antiflic dans les
manifes parce que j'ai fait 24 24
samedis de gilets jaunes. Je sais qu'il
y en a une cinquantaine ou une
soixantaine même plus. J'en ai fait que
24. Les 24 fois, j'ai eu les jetons
parce que les mecs en face, je parle pas
des gendarmes mais les mecs en face qui
mettent des casques qui vont acheter
dans le commerce des genouillères qui
sont en jean les bacux qui ont le la
matraque, les mecs qui sont contents
dans les commiss Ouais, c'est moi qui
est le le LBD, c'est moi qui l' samedi
prochain, c'est moi qui l' mec sont
contents d'aller faire des cartons. Il y
a des flics qui me l'ont confirmé et pas
des petits,
des grands flics. des flics qui sont
dans les protections rapprochées de
personnalités, des gens qui sont d'un
calme olympien qui ont l'habitude de
prendre des risque. Ils te disent "Je
vais dans les commissariats, moi quand
je fais mon footing, je veux prendre des
douches dans les commissariats."
Elle me dit, "Dans celui-là là, c'est
une bande de débile." Je dis "Mais
pourquoi tu dis ça ?" "Pils sont
contents qu'en samedi, il y en a un qui
dit "C'est moi qui aurait le LBD." Et
ceux-là dans les manifes, ouais, ils me
font peur. Ouais, je suis contre eux. Je
suis pas contre les flics de la brigade
financière qui vont emmerder les
banquiers hein. Je suis pas contre les
flics qui rentrent dans le dans l'hyper
cachet. Les mecs qui rentre alors qu'il
y a un fou dedans avec des kalashnikov,
il rentre avec le le truc blindé. J'ai
lu un livre d'un des d'un oublié son nom
d'un des mecs qui étaient au Bataclan.
Ça m'a touché. C'était incroyablissime.
J'ai lu ce bouquin. J'étais pour la
première fois, je ressentais
ce que quelqu'un qui était à l'intérieur
pouvait ressentir. Moi, j'ai j'étais pas
à l'intérieur. On était pas nous à
l'intérieur. On peut pas savoir. On voit
ça de loin, on dit "Oh, c'est atroce."
Le mec qui le vit, qui est
waouh quand il raconte, c'est
incroyable. et il raconte qu'il est
devenu copain avec les mecs de la
baillerie qui sont rentrés et qu'il les
voit et il me dit "C'est des gens
extraordinaires." Effectivement quand tu
vois les types qui rentrent dans l'hyper
cacher
[grognement] je sais que c'est
masculiniste de dire ça mais coucoette
hein. Et c'est leur boulot. Ils font que
leur boulot. Personne sait qui c'est et
c'est bien qu'on sache pas qui c'est.
C'est incroyable. Donc oui cela immense
respect. Immense respect. Quand un flic
se fait flinguer à Charlie Hebdo, tu vas
pas aller dire "Oh bah s'il a fait son
boulot." Non, immense respect. Les la
manif, les gens applaudissaient les
flics. Merci de nous nous protéger. Et
après tu vas dans une manife, les mêmes
ils tirent des des des du LBD dans la
gueule des gens. Il faudrait dire
"Ouais, bon ça va, vous avez été gentil
il y a 6 mois." Non, ceux qui font ça,
c'est des [__] Et quand ils sont
protégés par leur ministère, toute leur
hiérarchie et que jamais on ne fait
rien,
bah alors oui oui, on devient un petit
peu antiflic, anti ces flics là. Mais on
peut pas être antiflic, ça veut rien
dire. Ça a pas de sens. Moi à chaque
fois que j'ai un problème, je veux voir
la police hein. On me vole ma mobylette,
police, je perds un truc, police, j'ai
un problème, quelqu'un m'insulte, me
menace de mort, police. Et merci d'être
là les gars pour moi. Mais dans les
manifes, quand on vous donne l'ordre de
tirer,
refusez l'ordre. Cross en l'air les
gars.
Intelligente.
Ouais.
Tu regardes un peu les informations, tu
fais comment pour t'informer ? Alors, je
m'informe.
Quelle est l'information qui t'a le fait
le plus rire et qui t'a le rendu le plus
triste ces dernières semaines ?
Est-ce que c'est la tarte à teint ?
Ah, la tarte à teint,
on a fait un truc hier dans le JT de
Blast là-dessus.
On a fait
en fait ça s'est passé en deux temps
dans toutes les rédactions. Si j'ai
quand même gardé des copains, on se
parle et dans toutes les réda quand il a
mangé sa baffe, tout le monde a fait "Oh
la vache !" Il a pris pleine poire. Oh
là là là bien fait pour sa gueule. Et
puis ensuite tout le monde fait
[raclement de gorge] bon enfin c'est le
président hein. Ouais bon et puis hop
ils vont tous à l'antenne en disant
nous condamnons avec la la plus ferme
des positions.
C'est cette agression du président de la
République car c'est la démocratie que
l'on frappe chaque fois que et quand on
crève un œil c'est tout le monde qui
prend aussi comment ça se passe. Et en
fait il y a une hypocrisie chez les
journalistes qui sont tous marrés tous.
[grognement] sont foutu de sa gueule
mais grand mais après
officiellement mais officieusement
il a beaucoup d'hypocrisie chez les
journaliste
je sais pas si je fais de la pub pour
xantia parce que j'avais en tête il faut
bien qu'il paye les traites de la Xia
diesel quoi.
Il y a un livre, je crois que c'est je
crois que c'est une thèse d'Alain à
Cardau qui s'appelle socioanalysme du
socioanalyse du journalisme
qui explique assez bien
pourquoi les journalistes sont comme ça.
Comment
un peu soumis
n'étant pas très courageux
et c'est pas de leur faute en fait ils
sont tous issus à peu près du même
milieu social. C'est la classe moyenne
pour faire simple. Ils sont de la classe
moyenne.
Ils se rêvent au-dessus
et ils ont peur d'en bas.
Et dans ces euh dans ces moments où ils
doivent exister,
l'idée de critiquer
euh
ceux qui pourraient les oppresser parce
qu'ils sont payés pour la plupart des
clopinettes, il y a que les grands
journalistes qui prennent des blindes,
les autres c'est du stagiaire ça c'est
pas bien payé mais ça espère être payé
de la classe sociale où il viennent, ils
défendent le système qui les
qui les nourrit. d'une certaine façon et
ils n'ont pas l'idée même d'écouter
un un mouvement social autrement que par
ça va gêner les usagers, ça va gêner les
consommateurs. Ils ne peuvent pas
l'imaginer autrement. C'est jamais C'est
normal qu'ils défendent leur biftech ces
gens. C'est normal que les profs ils
disent "Qu'est-ce que c'est que ce
bordel que vous nous foutez dans les
universités ? On me supprime des cours,
que j'ai des amis profs qui ont plus de
cours, mec, ils ont bac + 8, ils sont
docteurs en je sais pas quoi et en
littérature d'ailleurs et on leur
supprime des cours en disant ouais mais
vos histoires là de littérature
algérienne de machin s'en fout un peu
hein donc vous allez arrêter et donc ils
n'ont plus de cours, ils ont plus de
travail bac + 8 payer 1500 balles par
mois mon fils il vend des des casquettes
en ce moment en boulot d'étudiants 1700
balles à mi-temps.
[grognement] C'est bizarre quand même.
an
ouais
c'est bien.
Ah ouais c'est énorme. Non mais il a le
cul bordé de nouille lui. Je sais pas
comment il se démerde. Il a trouvé ce
boulot là et tu vois ça tu dis ouais
effectivement je comprends que il soit
pas content les infirmières. Ah on les
applaudit on leur file une médaille en
chocolat. OK
1500 balles à pleintemps quand c'est pas
les infirmières.
Ouais
c'est plutôt 1250 1500 € par mois à
pleintemps.
Oui. Bah oui. À plein temps plus plus.
Bah oui. Bah donc c'est normal qu'elle
gueule. Ça serait normal que on s'en
occupe. Et bien quand un journaliste a
relaté ça, c'est toujours machin dans
les mouvements euh dans les hôpitaux.
Attention, vous allez être gêné si vous
allez aux urgences. Attention euh ce ce
service là et risque de de d'être en
saturation
ou parce que les infirmières sont pas
là, elles ne font que 35 he donc on a
besoin qu'elles sont là. payez-leur
leurs heures supplémentaires déjà et
puis embaucher des infirmières. Il y en
a pas, on en trouve pas. Je sais bien,
vous allez être obligé de faire venir
des infirmières de étrangère pour que ça
fonctionne sur les 35 he sur les
infirmières par exemple, il fallait
embaucher 200000 personnes.
Ils ont pas embauché. Donc effectivement
si elles se mettent à faire que 35 he et
que tu embauches personne,
bah ça ça dysfonctionne.
J'ai une question internet.
Ah
que pense-tu ?
Il y a quelqu'un à cette heure-là dans
internet ? Ouais, il y en a plein
d'ailleurs même.
Que pense-t-il du fait que les débats
politiques aient lieu chez Hanouna ?
Le débat politique a lieu chez Hanouna.
Que pensent-il du fait que les débats
politiques aient lieu chez Hanouna ?
C'est un fait. J'en sais rien. Je
regarde pas Anouna.
Je n'ai jamais regardé Hanouna. Je suis
allé faire son émission il y a 5 ou 6
ans
parce qu'on je sais pas, c'était
marrant. Je suis allé, c'était
inoffensif et puis je l'ai regardé
quelque fois et je suis pas la cible. Je
suis pas la cible pour Hanouna. Je j'ai
63 pig, j'ai un cerveau. Qu'est-ce que
tu veux que j'aille [__] chez Hanouna
?
Donc non, je regarde pas. Je sais pas.
Il y a le débat politique chez Anouna.
Bah me regardez pas comme ça. Oui, vous
sais pas. Je sais que Chiapa y est allé
mais
c'est qui Chiapa ? Je déconne.
Bah voilà. Non, je voilà moi je
travailleur
ça lui fait pas mal au cœur de voir ce
qui est devenu Canal Plus.
Alors pareil, je me suis désabonné, j'ai
rendu tous mes abonnements, je ne
regarde plus. Je regarde plus Canal
Plus.
Ça a commencé à me faire mal au cœur
contre ces messers qui a pris la
boutique parce que
ce fameux esprit canal qui n'était pas
un esprit, ça a jamais existé l'esprit
canal. qui est une invention de
journaliste. C'est simplement que la
cooptation entre gens qui riaent à peu
près des mêmes choses parce que l'humour
était quand même la base à Canal.
Rousselet en premier qui a un humour de
fou. Rousselet faut lire son bouquin à
mi parcours. C'est extraordinaire livre
sur la vie de Rousselet un mec qui avait
un humour fou
de greffe l'escur. C'était plutôt des
gens permissifs avec de l'humour.
Pas toujours mais avec de l'humour. Et
puis le reste c'était ça qui nous liait.
C'était cet humour même si ça se tirait
dans les pattes entre Carles Zé les
Guignoles de Côes les nuls, les machitié
mais on avait tous de l'humour et on
trouvait tous que les autres étaient
quand même rigolo et on était parfois
jaloux on se disant les [__] mais et
quand Messi est arrivé l'humour a
commencé à plus être la base. Mais il se
laissait faire parce qu'il y connaissait
rien. Puis après, il y a eu Me qui
connaissait encore moins mais qui était
pas si con que ça Mais eu parce qu'il a
compris qu'il fallait qu'il foute la
paix au transgressif,
tu vois. Si c'est ça qui fait de
l'abonnement alors je laisse faire ça.
Ce que faisait Rousselet au départ.
Et puis après
les choses changent et puis après il y a
eu Boloré qui a acheté la boutique et
Boloré est un catholique
plutôt rigoureux
qui a déclaré qu'il voulait que l'humour
bon c'était bien mais avec les autres
pas avec soi-même. Et puis bah l'humour
on a vu quoi. Il a il a arrêté tout ce
qu'il y avait d'humour dans la chaîne.
Il y a plus d'humour dans la chaîne. Il
y a plus d'émission dédié à ça. Et
ce qui aurait remplacé, alors encore une
fois, j'emploie le conditionnel parce
que je regarde pas, c'est Anouna qui
ferait de la déconne quoi et de la
déconne pure.
Mais je je sais pas, je regarde pas.
Question internet. Philippe Devil a
reconnu sur ce plateau [rires]
3h30, je l'ai pas encore regardé.
Regarde, c'est très intéressant.
Ben, je vais le regarder, je vais le
faire. Donc Philippe Deviler a reconnu
sur ce plateau avoir été massacré par
les guignoles.
Ah ouais ?
Vous lui répondiez quoi ?
Bah pas assez. Visiblement, tu es encore
debout.
Franchement le neneœux, on n pas tapé
assez fort. Qu'est-ce qui
le mec il est enf Nous, on s'est amusé
avec lui parce qu'il faisait le puit du
fou avec ses trucs médiévaux et que il
est quand même un peu rigoriste quand
même. Tu vois, on lui avait fait dire
une fois, on n'est pas obligé de mettre
un préservatif
sur une érection.
Il faut mettre quoi ? Un survêtement.
Ça me faisait barrer. Tu Mais ouais,
c'était de la rigolade quoi.
Il a il a l'impression qu'il a été
massacré lui.
Tu es encore debout gars. Tu vois la
preuve il a raison assitôt ? C'est votre
moment profite.
Comment tu vois l'avenir en France pour
les 5 prochaines années ? Est-ce que tu
vois les gens se tendre ? Est-ce que tu
vois les gens plus se donner la main ?
Est-ce que tu vois les médias arrêter de
faire du passage de plat ? Est-ce que tu
vois des intellectuels essayer de tendre
la main et faire des ponts ou ils
continuent à se à cultiver leur business
en silo et à surtout canceller ce qui
n'est pas dans leur silo ? C'est-à-dire
qu'est-ce que tu penses d'ailleurs du du
mouvement la cancelle culture ? Est-ce
que la can tu sais c'est empêcher les
gens de parler, de leur donner la
parole, les mettre dans un trou et
fermer le trou, leur couper leur
financement, leur couper leurs paroles,
leur couper leur ton d'antenne.
Est-ce que ça c'est productif ?
Non, parce que ça va naître ailleurs.
C'est
ça. Tu peux pas empêcher l'eau de
passer. L'eau, elle passe. La bêtise,
elle passe. Là, la bêtise, les vannes
sont ouvertes, ça en plein flot. Donc
c'est pas la peine d'aller se mettre
devant et d'essayer d'arrêter. Ça
marchera pas. Je suis d'un pessimisme
noir. Je je suis je suis vraiment
désolé. Moi, je suis très très
pessimiste. Ouais.
Comment ? Mais mets des mots dessus.
Est-ce que tu peux mettre des mots
dessus ? Sur mon pessimisme,
regardez le film idiocratie.
Idiocratie, c'est un film. Alors,
certains disent c'est de le génisme et
tout ça. C'est pas ça tout à fait du
tout même. Idiocratie pour ceux qui
l'ont pas vu. Alors ceux qui l'ont vu
vont se faire chier pendant
l'explication. Les autres non. C'est
l'armée américaine qui fait une
expérience qui prend l'Américain le plus
moyen possible
et qui le congèle. Criogénise, on
appelle ça avec une prostituée et ils
veulent le décongeler quelques temps
après pour voir ce qui s'est passé dans
son cerveau. Là, il y a des restrictions
de budget. Le truc est abandonné. On
ouvre le sarcophage dans lequel il était
500 ans après.
Le sarcophage se réouvre tout seul.
Oui, il se réouvre tout seul. Je sais
plus comment c'est. En fait ça ça tient
pas debout parce que tu peux pas il faut
quand même que ce soit dans un truc
congelé mais enfin bon peu importe. Le
mec se réveille 500 ans après dans un
monde où le président des États-Unis est
un buddy builder qui peut ressembler à
notre ami qui tire à la Kalashnikov
d'ailleurs en l'air sur un truc
il est noir d'ailleurs
et il est noir enfin ça la couleur je
m'en fous mais euh mais qui tire en
l'air et tout le monde est devenu
complètement idiot et la première chose
que fait le mec en se réveillant il va
demander de l'eau. Il dit je pasux peux
voir j'ai vous avez pas une bouteille
d'eau ? Mais il dit de l'eau ? Mais non
si tu veux boire il y a le tel produit
je sais pas ce que c'est il y a de
l'électrolyse dedans. Il faut boire ça.
Il dit non non je veux juste de l'eau.
Il dit de l'eau comme dans les chiottes.
Il comprend pas. Et petit à petit, on se
rend compte que les compagnies ont
acheté
les les multinationales de
l'agroalimentaire ont acheté l'eau pour
l'enlever en fait et pour que les les
boissons qui font roter ou péter là, ce
qu'on boit encore régulièrement en
France
servent jusqu'à arroser les champs et là
il s'étonne que rien ne pousse.
Et lui qui est un mec moyen dit juste à
un moment s'il faut mettre de l'eau. Je
dis mais non l'eau c'est pour les
chiottes
et il est pris pour un fou. Il est
condamné, on va on va le tuer. Enfin
c'est n'importe quoi dans des jeux du
cirque.
Etan Cohen un des deux frères Cohen qui
est plutôt un intellectuel a déclaré il
y a pas si longtemps que ça je ne
pensais pas qu'occratie deviendra un
documentaire. Et ce qui me fait peur
aujourd'hui, ce qui crée mon pessimisme,
c'est que je pense qu'on ne peut pas
endiguer cette bêtise qui est en route.
On peut pas l'endiguer, il y en a trop.
Tu peux boucher une fuite, mais quand un
barrage pète, c'est fini. Et là, on
prend de la flotte en pleine poire et
c'est fini. Alors, il y a deux solutions
dans ces cas-là. Soit tu vas mettre ton
corps devant la mitraille et tu'en
prends plein la gueule. Soit tu fais de
laido et tuesquives. Et tous les animaux
font ça. Ils se battent que quand ils
sont dos au mur et [grognement] que ce
qui est de plus fort queeux, même en
face d'eux, ils vont rentrer dedans.
Moi, j'ai pas de mur derrière moi et je
vais fuir. Je vais me barrer. Ils ont
gagné, je me tire. Enfin, en même temps,
je représente rien mais je vais me
barrer parce que rien ne m'indique que
ça va aller mieux. Rien.
Surtout pas une élection.
est triste
qui sourit tu vois qui j'ai plombé
l'ambiance Macron.
Macron repasse les doigts dans le pif.
Gardez-la celle-là.
S'il passe pas, s'il se présente pas, tu
payes ta tournée.
Ah ben s'il paye pas, je reviens ici et
j'explique pourquoi. Non mais il y a la
seule la seule configuration dans
laquelle il peut perdre, c'est un
deuxième tour avec Marine Le Pen.
Parce que un deuxième tour avec la M Le
Pen,
je suis pas sûr que cette fois en je
pense qu'il gagne mais ça sera un 48 52
cette fois parce que j'ai des copains
qui sont très de gauche qui disent "J'en
ai rien à [__] je vais aller voter Le
Pen." Je dis "Vous êtes dingue les
mecs." J'en ai rien à [__] ça va
[__] la merde. Non non, faites pas ça.
N'oubliez pas en 80 Chiraak qui appelle
à voter Mitéran en disant il a un
cancer, il aura pas la majorité à la
chambre, on va gagner les législatives
et lui il finira par démissionner.
C'était ça son calcul à Chirac en 80 14
ans de Mitéron, il s'est tapé balaise.
Et là le calcul Le Pen, c'est pas grave,
ça va [__] le bordel. Les gens vont se
révolter. mon cul. Ils l'attendent.
Ils l'attendent. Ils attendent ça. Ils
veulent de l'ordre. Ils veulent euh que
68 disparaissent. Ils veulent que euh
tout ce qui est bien fait,
bienveillance, aide, euh
tout ce qui est social disparaisse. Le
CNR disparaisse.
Conseil national de la Résistance.
Voilà. Roosevelt,
les accords de Breton Woods, tous ces
bordels là. fini termin la rigolade.
Moi ça me fout les jetons d'ailleurs il
est je dis Macron je le trouve moi je
serai lui je pousserai Mélenchon au lieu
de taper dessus je dirais mais euh c'est
le c'est le mieux c'est le mec qui euh
qui a le le un discours politique un
discours républicain, un discours dans
les grands moments qui est toujours
équilibré. Il pète des câbles de temps
en temps. Mais
des fois ça c'est il pète des câbles, il
est incompris, il s'exprime mal sa
dernière sortie. Qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé
là de quoi
quand il a dit voilà, il y a toujours
des des l'instrumentalisation
d'événements graves avant les émission,
ainsi de suite. Moi je l'ai compris
comme ça.
Oui. Moi je l'ai compris comme ça aussi
mais c'était tantant pour ses
adversaires de dire "C'est un
complotiste." Franchement, ça aurait été
dans l'autre sens. J'aurais fait pareil
avec un autre moi. Mais euh quand tu
écoutes bien le truc, c'est vrai que la
phrase est mal foutue parce qu'il met
plusieurs choses. Il dit "Si moi je veux
que Macron se présente parce que moins
lui il a un bilan et on pourra critiquer
son bilan mais si lui il se présente
pas, ils vont sortir quelqu'un d'autre
du chapeau.
Bah les mêmes qu' avait mis Macron,
Drahi,
Mimi Marchand,
Arnaud, enfin tous les tous les gens qui
se sont dit Hollande il vaut pas un
calot, il va il va pas nous gagner une
course le mec il faut changer de cheval.
Lui c'est un bouricot, on va mettre un
cheval de course et ils ont eu de la
chance parce que les planètes se sont
alignées. Si Fillion expose pas en vol,
les drais machin sont derrière Fillion.
Alignement des planètes, ça se dit la
sizigie.
La sisigie.
Très [grognement] bien. Je très bien. Je
question internet. Est-ce que Big il
fait toujours de l'humour ?
[rires]
Mais c'est alors pardonne-moi
Jean-Marie, je connais Jean-Marie depuis
très longtemps et je connais pas Papa
Sito.
Il fait il fait ce que fait Papa Sito.
En fait, il se met à être haineux.
sur une scène. J'ai vu le passage sur
internet là de où il parle de comment
elle s'appelle ? Des buusins.
Je veux même pas prononcer les mots.
C'est pas la peine de l'insulter une
nouvelle fois.
Bon, il est bourré, je sais pas ce qu'il
a. Bon, voilà, ça il y a même
l'organisatrice qui
[grognement] Jean-Marie, arrête. Il dit
"Oh, il est populaire, tiens, on va le
prendre."
Et j'ai vu une phrase qui m'a fait rire
sur internet encore quand là là l'autre
il fait son Tour de France là Macron
c'est un Tour de France il y a que le
maillot jaune qui court toi les autres
on leur dit et
bah il y a qu'un cycliste en fait il y a
la caravane et un cycliste c'est tout
pour
Macron maillot jaune c'est ça
c'est Macron maillot jaune. les deons et
toute la caravane derrière.
C'est pas le titre d'un bouquin ça
d'ailleurs ?
H
c'est pas le titre d'un bouquin
d'ailleurs.
D'un quoi ?
D'un livre.
Ah je sais pas avec le masque. Vous êtes
chiant les gars. J'entends rien ce que
vous racontez. Je suis sourd. Parlez
haut je suis vieux. Et il y avait écrit
très sérieusement un titre genre le
monde ça. Emmanuel Macron a rencontré
Patrick Sébastien. C'est lui qui lui
avait présenté Jean-Marie Billard. Tu
dis ah ouais c'est bon niveau. Le mec il
doit se dire attends Sébastien très
populaire big très populaire faut que je
m'en approche. Tout d'un coup c'est ça
lui pétonnait. Tu
Patrick Sébastien il avait pas essayé de
créer un truc qui s'appelait le DAR ou
un truc comme ça ?
Oui oui oui oui. C'est un parti
Oui. Un parti politique un truc. Oui
mais tout le monde essaye. Je veux me
présenter au présidentiel.
J'ai entendu que Zemour il pensait que
Anouna voulait le faire, qu'il y a une
une rappeuse qui veut le faire aussi,
une chanteuse. Et ben je vous l'annonce
ce soir solennellement,
je vais poser ma candidature pour les
élections présidentielles de 2022.
N'importe qui peut le faire maintenant.
Bon, je vous garantis pas que j'aurai
les 500 signatures pour y arriver. Ça ça
on est où euh
l'association que tu avais fait ? OK.
Sur le sur porte et plainte contre les
dirigeants tout.
Ah Covid
euh Covid
sur la gestion de crise sanitaire.
Ouais ouais ouais.
Ça, on est où ?
Alors 200000 téléchargements des
plaintes. Je ne sais pas combien ont
vraiment rempli les plaintes. Il y a eu
beaucoup beaucoup de plaintes de déposé
je le sais. Et c'est a priori en attente
parce qu'il y a eu 20 ou 30000 plaintes
de déposé.
Ça sera traité un jour forcément, c'est
obligé. rafraîchis un peu la mémoire aux
gens qui n'ont pas suivi ce petit
épisode et qui
alors c'est parti d'un avocat qui
s'appelle Divisio qui a défendu des
médecins qui avaient parce qu'on leur
disait faut pas porter de masque ou on
leur donnait pas le matériel et tout ça
et ils avaient fait une assaut pour
porter les plaines collectivement et
j'avais demandé sur internet j'avais dit
mais comment on peut faire nous pour se
pour s'associer à cette plainte parce
qu'on nous a dit que les masques étaient
pas obligatoires et que ça servait à
rien alors que quand même a priori On le
sait depuis euh 25 ans. Pour une maladie
euh dont le virus se transmet par les
voies respiratoires, la première chose à
faire, c'est ce que vous faites ici,
c'est de protéger le nez et la bouche,
de se laver les mains.
Les yeux et les yeux
et les yeux et de se laver les mains et
pour éviter de de contracter le virus.
C'est la première chose. On met une
barrière à notre propre frontière. Et
là, on nous a dit pendant 3 semaines, un
mois, ça sert à rien juste parce qu'ils
en avaient pas. Et donc j'ai demandé
est-ce qu'on peut porter plainte ? J'ai
été contacté par des avocats en me
disant "Non, mais on est en train de
regarder un truc, peut-être qu'il y a
des possibilités." Alors, je me souviens
plus exactement, il y avait mise en mise
en danger d'autrui. Il y avait un
problème d'information aussi, je crois
et il y avait homicide involontaire
puisqu'il y a des gens qui étaient morts
à cause de de cette malveillance là
[soupir][souffle coupé]
et je sais plus quoi. Il y avait quatre
motifs de plainte et ça avait très très
très bien marché. Et c'est de là que
Twitter m'a bloqué, m'a invisibilisé. En
fait, c'est quand on a fait ce truc-là,
euh il y a, je crois, près de 10 ou
15000 personnes qui sont venues sur mon
compte et qui se sont abonnés à mon
compte. Et je suis arrivé assez
rapidement à 95000 et depuis, je suis
bloqué à 95. Ça bouge plus. Ça bouge de
100, 150, 12, 20,
je sais pas. Donc ça s'est arrêté net.
Tu as peur des Tu as peur des réseaux
sociaux ?
Est-ce que tu as peur ? Est-ce que tu as
peur que les réseaux sociaux soient
faunés
pour euh faire de l'astroturfing,
c'est-à-dire rendre l'opinion publique
malléable et la diriger vers tel ou tel
courant ?
C'est une [__] de bonne question ça
parce que c'est trop tard.
C'est encore trop tard le fait de dire
je vais y réfléchir des gens dis bah tu
vois tu penses que ça va complotter euh
est-ce que ça existe ? C'est les deep
fake, ça s'appelle, où on fait vraiment
des euh du morphing. En fait, c'est
vraiment les gens, c'est super flippant
ces trucs-là. C'est super flippant les
deep fake. Donc effectivement, tu peux
faire dire n'importe qui et n'importe
quoi, faire tourner la sauce et le temps
que ça soit démenti, c'est mort. Euh,
c'est trop tard, c'est passé. Donc
l'accumulation je pense de ces deep fake
va faire que même quelqu'un disant
quelque chose de vrai d'intelligent ne
sera plus cru et que donc le truc va se
tariir de lui-même. Il y a rien qui
remplace
la lecture
de bouquins.
Même sur internet, vous pouvez les lire
les bouquins, mais qui sont pensés,
éditorialisés,
fait par des gens qui ont quelque chose
à raconter. qui ont pris le temps de le
raconter en l'écrivant. Il y a rien qui
remplace ça. Euh le reste c'est que des
euh
c'est que des moyens de faire passer
vite fait des choses quoi. Mais c'est
toi, c'est vous qui êtes des
spécialistes de l'internet ici. Vous
savez pas si euh si les Russes ils font
des trucs avec justement la structure
things. Les Russes ils bossent dessus,
ils essayent vraiment d'influencer par
les Russes. Il y a les Coréens, les
Américains, les Qataris, les
les français font bien aussi non ? Les
Polonais, les Ukrainiens, tous tous. Et
tu sais comment ils font ?
Non.
Ils ont des petites usines à troll.
Ah oui oui.
Des fois des grosses usines à troll.
D'ailleurs, l'usine troll de troll russe
qui était à Saint-Pétersbourg.
Ouais.
a déménagé pour des locaux encore plus
grands.
Ah ouais.
Et et euh pour la petite anecdote que je
te raconterai euh
bah vas-y raconte-la, lâche-toi,
profite profite de ton Syerview. J'ai
j'ai Non, un jour tu me prends mon
interview. Un jour, j'étais j'étais
invité à une
pas une conférence de presse mais dans
un sing tank où on parlait de ça, où il
y avait des Russes qui parlaient de ça
et je me retrouve par caméra interposée
en face du du mec qui était censé gérer
la communication du gouvernement russe.
Je lui dit "Écoutez-moi bien, c'est quoi
cette petite histoire d'usine à troll
qui pourrit les relations franco-russes
Et le mec, il nous a fait un réflexe de
Lawrence. Il a commencé à avaler sa
salive. Et [grognement] puis c'est
bizarre, mon matériel ne devait pas être
suffisamment bien. Ils ont fait comme
les français font d'habitude. C'est je
ne comprends pas la question. Vous
pouvez répéter la question, on vous
entend mal. On vous entend mal.
Ah oui,
mais il faudrait que je fasse ça avec
d'autres puissances. D'ailleurs, aux
États-Unis, il y a 600 personnes qui
travaillent sous sous couverture pour
influencer les réseaux sociaux. Oui.
Et et l'internet est vraiment devenu
un terrain de guerre.
Ah non mais ça alors ça j'en suis
certain. et et les petits lobis que ce
soit des lobis de gauche, de droite,
d'extrême droite, d'extrême centre,
ainsi de suite, ils ont tous leur petite
armée
et ce qu'ils ont pas compris, c'est que
des fois, ils peuvent se faire aussi
traquer leurs idéologues pour savoir qui
est-ce qui allume les feux comme les
usines à troll russes ou comme les
usines à troll américains.
Ce serait pas un poil complotiste. Non,
a quelqu'un euroinfolable qui a essayé
de traquer des gens comme ça, qui a fait
ça n'importe comment d'ailleurs
sans anonymiser les data et ainsi de
suite. Mais mais c'est très intéressant
ce qui se passe sur les réseaux sociaux
et il faut surtout endurcir son esprit
critique pour éviter de tomber dans ces
vagues qui débarquent sur l'opinion
public qui c'est d'ailleurs c'est
d'ailleurs totalement contre-productif
parce que ça laisse la population
euh au cas devant de toutes les
propagandes, c'est-à-dire essayer de les
tirer à gauche à droite les tirer la
couverture vers soi et ainsi de suite,
on se retrouve avec des gens qui
n'arrivent plus à à [gémissement]
avoir leur esprit critique
c'est tu sais il y a des gens qui
parlent de révolution armée pour cette
petite apparentée que je ne permets
jamais
non mais ouais c'est vrai c'est vrai tu
fais jamais ça me fait super plaisir que
tu l'ai fait avec moi. Ça veut dire que
tu es à l'aise. Tu vas répondre à mes
questions maintenant.
Et ben non.
Tu viens d'où ? [rires]
Tu es qui ? Tu fais quoi ? Alors
continue, je te pose des questions sur
lieu donné parce que là
non mais je terminer avec ça les gens il
y a des gens qui parlent de révolution
armée encore aujourd'hui. Je dis mais
vous avez vu juste les flics dans la rue
comme ils ont des des armes de guerre
dans la rue d'abord les terroristes ont
gagné pessimiste
mais évidemment on nous dit il faut
lutter contre le terrorisme. Qu'est-ce
qu'il veut le terrorisme terrorisé ? Bah
c'est gagné tout le monde est terrorisé.
Il y a des gens armés d'armes de guerre,
arnachés comme s'ils étaient en guerre
et peut-être [raclement de gorge] qu'ils
le sont. Enfin, eux le sont sans doute
dans leur tête.
Dans la population civile, il y a des
gens comme ça dans les terrasses. On a
vu cette image.
On est en alerte terroriste. On est
Batclan, il y a Samuel Patti qui se fait
trancher la tête. Les flics se font
agresser au couteau.
Et donc bah c'est normal. Bah donc les
terroristes ont déjà gagné.
Alors il faudrait faire quoi ? Et tout
le monde en maillot de bain et se
balader
et oui. Non mais tu vois voilà ça c'est
la caricature de l'autre côté. Tu vois
que tu peux caricaturer et faire de
l'humour.
Tu peux pas faire la guerre au
terrorisme ça veut rien dire. C'est un
substant un substantif abstrait le
terrorisme. Tu peux faire la guerre à
des terroristes. Tu fais pas la guerre à
des terroristes
en slip évidemment. Il faut aller il
faut aller les buter jusqu'à sur les
chiottes disait l'autre. Il faut faire
le maximum pour que ces gens n'existent
plus mais
ne pas leur donner le point à chaque
fois. Ce qu'ils veulent c'est que notre
société soit en déséquilibre, que les
gens se tirent dessus les uns les
autres. Ça marche. Ça marche. Il y a des
gros énervés masculinistes tatoués de
partout qui disent "Maintenant, c'est
fini les gens de gauche, on vous tapez
sur la gueule. Le retour de bâton, vous
allez en prendre plein la gueule.
L'islam plein la gueule. Machin plein la
gueule. Bah, ils ont gagné, ils ont créé
le bordel,
ce qui est très difficile et je suis pas
en train de dire voilà ce que devrait
faire un gouvernement pour que ça aille
mieux. Ce qui est très difficile dans
n'importe quelle société, quel que soit
le système de gouvernance, c'est de
parvenir à cet équilibre qui crée une
harmonie relative. C'est toujours
déséquilibrer une société. Il y aura
toujours des riches et des pauvres. Ce
qu'il faut, c'est que le pauvre se sente
pas humilié
à 100 % par le riche. Il y a des gens
qui sont pauvres qui savent qu'ils n'ont
pas les capacités de gagner 15, 20,
30000 balles par mois parce que leur
formation, leurs envies, leur cursus
et le pauvre, le pauvre qui se fait
humilier toute la journée par des
petites tracailles qui lui cassent les
couilles toute la journée quand il
rentre du taf parce qu'il a travaillé
toute la semaine, il p ses impôts, il
pareil pareil. Question internet Bruno,
pour une expérience sociale, serais-tu
prêt à déménager avec ta famille à la
cité des 4000 ou à Crayille ? Mais ça va
pas la tête. Non mais non, j'y vais pas.
Moi, j'habite à Saint-Germain d'Éprè les
gars. Faut arrêter de penser que euh
ça ne marcherait que si euh on allait au
contact. Moi, je viens du 106 de la rue
de La Richel Landière à Saint-Étienne.
C'était une cité.
C'était une cité violente. Je me
bagarais moi quand j'étais mom on se
battait mais nous on savait qu'on
pouvait sortir de la cité. On disait
dans le centre-ville, il nous aime pas.
Ils nous aiment pas. C'est des gens qui
nous aiment pas. Et puis au bout d'un
moment, les vieux, ils nous disaient
"Mais [__] mais allez travailler,
allez-y." Et on y allait. Et puis on se
disait "Bah finalement, ils s'en foutent
de nous si on est gentil, si on s'en
foutent."
Aujourd'hui, j'ai l'impression que la
cité c'est un nid.
C'est ça qui les protège. Il faut qu'il
soit dans la cité. Alors effectivement,
le mec qui habite encore en cité, qui
est pauvre et qui a un petit boulot, qui
se fait emmerder tous les jours, d'abord
il faudrait que ces gens-là viennent
parler et dire "Oui, on m'emmerde tous
les jours." Parce que moi, les exemples
que j'ai à l'époque où on travaillait au
guignol avec un
Ahmed Amidi, son père habitait toujours
à à Bondi, je crois, ils étaient, il
disait, "Tu sais, mon père parfois il
est contrôlé quand il rentre dans la
cité." Les gens lui disent "Mohamed,
viens voir. Ouais, donne-moi tes
papiers. truc absurde. Il y a la carte
CRS devant, la carte CRS derrière. Il
dit les gens qu'il faut glorifier dans
ces dans ces endroit qui ont été
c'est des endroits où on a mis tous les
gens qui allaient pas bien au même
endroit. Après, tu t'étonnes que trois
générations après les mecs, ils ont
envie de tout casser. Ouais, c'est un
vois c'est pas normal qu'il casse tout
hein, mais on peut comprendre le cursus,
le processus. Et euh il disait les les
gens qu'il faut admirer et à qui il
faudrait faire de la pub, c'est les gens
qui font tous les jours leur taf, qui
rentrent tous les jours dans cette cité
et qui ferment leur gueule et qui disent
rien et qui subissent parce que ils
auraient aussi des raisons de s'énerver.
Mais bien sûr que je veux je peux pas
dire je vais aller habiter dans la cité
des 4000 et avec ça ce serait génial. Je
pourrais comprendre. Non, je comprends
très bien. Je sais d'où je viens. Je
sais où il est le trou. J'ai pas envie
d'y retourner et il faut être très
honnête à Saint-Germain des Près, c'est
bien plus confortable qu'à la cité des
4000.
Question internet de Jo. Euh quels sont
ses rapports avec Dieu donné avec lequel
il a coécrit "Peut-on tout dire édité
par Robert Ménard" ?
Ça c'est bien qu'il est dit édité par
Robert Ménard parce que quand on veut
m'emmerder, on me dit "Ouais, tu as
écrit un lire avec Dieu donné." et je
suis obligé d'ajouter oui et publié par
Robert Ménard qui à l'époque était il
venait de quitter RSF. Il était pas
encore
Ouais. Il était pas encore maire de BI.
Et bah j'ai pas de rapport avec lui. Je
l'ai pas vu depuis qu'on faisait de la
promo ensemble à la télé pour le livre
où j'arrivais dans les chaînes de télé
en disant "Je suis pas venu tout seul,
je vous ai amené un copain nazi noir."
Les mec mais ça se passait bien, ça se
passait pas mal. Il est il était en
période où il avait envie de revenir, il
avait envie d'être toi de dire "OK, je
bon OK, qu'est-ce que vous me reprochez
exactement ?"
Et puis bon, j'ai plus de nouvelles. Je
sais qu'il a un truc qui s'appelle quen
plus ou je sais pas quoi. Je reçois sans
arrêt. Abonnez-vous, abonnez-vous, je
m'abonne pas. Je
Question Internet. L'humour fait-elle
rire ? Alors, l'humour fait-elle rire
pour oublier ? Provoque-elle une forme
de déni ?
Non, il doit éveiller.
Je pense au contraire, l'humour quand il
est enfin dans un certain domaine euh
qui serait plutôt l'humour caricatural,
politique, social, sociétal,
normalement,
il est clair par une image, on dit "Ah,
j'avais pas compris ce que ça voulait
dire." Là, je comprends mieux. Euh
bah nous on a quand même popularisé un
truc qui s'appelle la World Company. Les
gens ont fini par très bien comprendre
euh que les politiques n'étaient plus
les dépositaires du pouvoir mondial et
que le pouvoir dans le monde était
détenu par les gens qui ont l'argent. Et
les gens qui ont l'argent achètent les
politiques par le lobby. Enf il les
achètent. C'est pas peince sur la temp
l'oseille. C'est pas des Bah si, c'est
des mallettes quand même un peu mais euh
vu des mallettes ?
Des mtes j'en ai vu. Non mais on m'a on
m'a dit il est mort, je peux en parler.
André Rouslet.
André Rousselet quand je lui ai dit
[__] je parle de gens que vous
connaissez pas, c'est terrible. Vous
allez, je sais que vous êtes une
communauté très active. Vous allez taper
Guy de Joinier.
Guide de Joign était euh le patron de la
générale des eaux, je crois, et qui
était actionnaire de Canal Plus au
départ avec la société générale et Avas
et enfin bref et je dis à il y avait une
bataille entre de Joign et Rousselet à
un moment et je dis à Rousselet un jour,
on se voyait pas mal et je lui dis "Mais
vous l'avez rencontré comment de Joanny
?" Il me dit "La valise
comment ça ?" Benah il est venu avec une
mallette
la mallette pour Canal. Non, quand
j'étais directeur de cabinet de
Mitterran et trésorier de Mitterran
avant qu'il soit élu, il était trésorier
de Mitteran Rouset. Il dit, il est venu
avec la mallette, il m'a apporté la
mallette
avec de l'argent dedans. Ouais, ouais,
ouais. Pour le pour la campagne.
Je vous en avez pris un petit peu,
président. Ah non, donne la mallette.
Moi la mallette je l'ouvre pas, je la
transmets, hein. Mais c'est moi qui
recevait les mallettes. Et il dit donnez
tous.
Ouais, bravo et il en a jamais parlé. Il
a même pas dit dans son livre. Donc là,
je balance un truc qui est pas
vérifiable.
Mais enfin bon, voilà, faites-moi
confiance. C'est vrai.
En parlant de ma euh
les subvention au médias depuis 2019 euh
euh on y a on y'y a plus accès. C'est
qu'on sait pas qui touche quoi, qui
touche combien, quelle chaîne touche
combien et ainsi de suite.
Ouais.
Et
tu travailles bénévolement pour un média
qui s
Ouais, je travaille pour Blast, très bon
média.
Est-ce que vous allez traiter ce sujet
là un jour ? Est-ce que tu étais au
courant de ça ? Est-ce que tu peux Ou
oui, je je sais je sais que il y a les
euh que les enfin qu'il y a une caisse
pour les médias quoi et que les journaux
les grands journaux le monde le Figaro,
l'IB sont ceux qui touchent le plus en
fait. Et nous on n pas de subvention à
Blast, on a rien du tout. Et comme tu le
disais, je travaille bénévolement. Je
leur ai dit, je vous fais un mois
gratuit puisque j'ai du temps. Je leur
dis, je vous fais un mois gratuit et
puis on verra après si on reprend en
septembre le journal qu'on fait avec
Haute Gon Goubert et Patrick Chanfy.
Regardez celui de ce soir, il est
vraiment marrant.
Tu dis qu'il y a pas de subvention mais
il y a il y a forcément des subventions
s'ils ont leur carte de presse.
Non, c'est un milliardaire qui a lâché
l'oseille direct. Si s'ils ont leur
carte de presse, si c'est une agence de
presse ou quoi que ce soit, ils ont la
fiscalité presse.
Oh oui, je suis pas fiscale à 7500 €. la
TVA qui passe de 20 % à 2.5 ou quelque
chose comme ça.
Ouais, mais ça c'est des aides mais on
touche pas directement de l'oseille. Le
Figaro touche directement de l'oseille.
Nous on touche pas. Blast ça a commencé
sur un énervement de Denis qui s'est
fait virer. Alors, j'ai rien compris aux
raisons pour lesquelles il est parti de
du Le Média auquel j'avais participé
aussi au départ. J'avais participé, je
les aidais et euh je sais pas, il s'est
barré de là. Il était très colère et je
lui dis "Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?"
Donc j'ai sa version "Ouais, c'est des
Staliniens, il m'empêch de bosser."
Enfin bon, je ne sais pas
parce que c'est que sa version, j'ai pas
la version en face. Et euh
il était très très remonté et je lui dis
"Ben tuen cré un autre." Oh non, il dit
"C'est trop de boulot ce" et 3 jours
après, il dit "Ouais, on va refaire un
autre média et tout ça." Et euh je lui
dis "Bah écoute, je moi je t'aide, viens
on le fait. Comment on fait ?" Donc on a
commencé à discuter. Puis il y a eu des
des fondateurs, ils sont une douzaine je
crois. Moi j'en ai j'en suis pas, je
regardais ça de loin. Etth
Kiskiss Bang qui s'est ouvert et on a
fait 8700 ou 900000 € sur un Kiskiss en
même pas 50 jours ou 60 jours. C'est
énorme. Énormissime ça. Plus les gens
qui ont fait des dons et tout ça, on a
plus d'un million.
Sauf que faire des fiches de paye, c'est
énorme. Le fric qui sort, il y a 100000
balles qui sortent par mois, c'est
terrible. Puis après, il y a eu cette
histoire de milliardaire. Alors, je
sais, tout le monde a refusé ton argent,
moi je l'accepte. Vas-y, fais péter la
tune. Non, mais voilà.
Question d'internet,
que penses-t-il de cette phrase ? Tu tu
as le droit de penser ce que tu veux
tant que c'est pareil que moi. Sinon, tu
es un macho et il faut te détruire.
Tu es un fachot, pardon. Tu es un
fachot, il faut te détruire.
Qui dit ça ?
C'est capitaine Murk. Que pensent-il de
cette phrase ? Tu as le droit de penser
ce que tu veux
tant que c'est pareil que moi, sinon tu
es un fachot et il faut te détruire.
Ouais, c'est ce que disent les fachot
des gens de gauche qui leur disent "Vous
dites que des conneries". C'est ça.
Ouais, c'est des fachots. C'est des
connards en fait. Excuse-moi, tu es un
gros connard.
Est-ce que Est-ce que tu as Question
Internet a-t-il lu Éric Sadin l'air de
l'individu tyran la fin d'un monde
commun ?
Non, je sais même pas de quoi c'est qu'
parle.
Ça c'est pas une question.
Ça c'est pas une question sur un
commentaire. C'est ça.
Ouais, on voit ses couilles. [rires]
Comment tu vois le la jeunesse à l'heure
actuelle ? Est-ce que tu as encore des
rapports avec la jeunesse, mis à part
avec tes enfants ? Est-ce que Est-ce que
tu la vois évoluer ? Est-ce que tu
penses que tu as laissé ton empreinte ou
est-ce que ça tourne mal ? Est-ce que
est-ce que tu vois les les choses
tourner vinaigre ?
Définissons la jeunesse. Quel âge ? 14
15 ans.
14 15 ans. Je connais personne de 14 15
ans. Je connais plus personne de 14 15
ans. Mon Je connais mon fils qui a
je me souviens plus de son nom, il est
Je l'adore. En plus, c'est le dernier
euh il a 20 ans, il a des amis que je
vois de temps en temps, il montre des
entreprises, il s'amuse comme des fous
et je lui ai posé des questions
d'ailleurs, c'est je suis en train
d'écrire une autre pièce de théâtre qui
s'appelle Les hommes perdus qui parlent
de ça. Et je lui pose une question à mon
fils, je lui dis euh comment vous faites
pour les filles avec le Covid, le
masque, le le féminisme maintenant,
combien de fois tu insistes quand tu
dragues quelqu'un ? Comment ça se passe
?
Comment tu vois le monde à 20 piges ? Il
m'a dit "Tu sais, avec les copains, on
est assis, on bouffe du pop-corn et on
regarde votre monde s'écrouler."
J'ai dit "Waouh !
Et à côté de ça, il se démerde pour
trouver du boulot. Il veut faire science
pot. Il est il a une licence pour
l'instant, il va aller beaucoup plus
loin que ça de d'économie, de gestion.
Il a monté une entreprise, ils vont du
maté. Si vous aimez le maté, ça
s'appelle Tessail maté sur internet.
Fait pas de pub. Ça s'appelle Tessail
maté. Et vous pouvez y aller. C'est du
très bon maté. Euh, ils sont
C'est du maté des cocas ou c'est du maté
maté ? C'est du mathématé qui vient du
Brésil, Argentine, ils ont des
fournisseurs. Là, il était emmerdé hier,
il me voit, il me dit "J'ai des
problèmes avec les trucs de douane. Il
me demande de l'argent parce que pour
les droits de douane, je dis "Mais tu
crois quoi qu'il fait venir le maté par
euh tu vois ? C'est c'est pas des
liivérou le maté, c'est". Et donc il
découvre tout ce monde de taxe et de
machin, mais il est proactif.
Il est très proactif dans ce monde. Il
regarde beaucoup Syerview, il a regardé
plein de trucs sur Syerview. Il regarde
des conférences et sur l'économie, sur
l'écologie beaucoup et
ouais, il est il est inquiet comme moi.
On parle du du permafrost qui pète quoi.
C'est le le truc le plus fou du monde
ça. Que les Russes soient en train de
chercher les virus qui datent d'il y a
25000 ans ou 30000 ans pour se dire il
faut absolument qu'on trouve le vaincin
maintenant parce que ça va nous péter à
la gueule un jour. S'il dit mais surtout
la première chose faites pas tomber les
prouvettes parce que là ça va nous
[__] dans la merde.
Si si elle est en plastique ça va.
Si elle est en plastique ça va. Et si
elle se penche sur le côté que ça tu
vois mec il marche dedans, il en ramène
partout
tu vois. Donc tu vois donc déjà pétez
pas les prouvettes les gars, la
renversez pas. Et puis
on a bien compris que vous ne ferez rien
pour que la glace reste en place et que
vous allez gérer le bordel d'après. Mais
non pas empêcher le bordel. C'est trop
tard. On n'empêchera pas le bordel. Le
permafrost va péter. C'est fini. C'est
terminé. Les voies du du nord des
bateaux qui vont plus passer par le
canal de Suède et qui vont passer par le
haut et qui grâce à ça vont gagner 8000
km et des jours et des jours de
navigation. Donc ils vont gagner du
pognon. Il va falloir qu'il passe et
quand ils vont passer tu as les Russes,
les Américains, les Scandinaves, tous
les mecs vont dire "E faut payer la taxe
en passant." "Ah mais c'est à qui la
banquise ? Il y en a plus. Bah ça passe
chez moi. Non, tu passes chez moi.
Qu'est-ce qui va se passer là-haut ?" Et
je crois alors j'ai lu l'info, faudrait
qu'on la confirme mais j'aimerais cette
communauté merveilleuse de Syerview
me confirme ça. Il y aurait
dans l'Arctique
plus de pétrole que euh Arabie Saoudite,
Qatar, Émirat arabe unis réunis et de
gaz. Faut qu'on confirme ça même s'il y
en a avec la moitié. Tu penses qu'on va
faire une transition écologique quand
les grands pétroliers vont se rendre
compte qu'en faisant des trous, ils vont
encore sortir 100 ans de pétrole ? On
fera pas. Donc 100 ans de pétrole, c'est
du plastique. Donc on ne fera pas. Donc
le réchauffement où il fallait rester
selon les le rapport du JC de 2018 ou
2019 qui disait que si on n'était pas à
+ 2°gr en 2020, c'était mort. On le
tiendra pas. On est en 2021. les 2
degrés, on va les passer mais et on
[raclement de gorge] va aller sur 4 5 6
peut-être, je sais pas. Donc je commence
à revenir
sur ce que disait Steven Hawkin avant de
mourir.
Euh en l'espèce humaine aura disparu.
Et donc c'était très pessimiste venant
d'un d'un cerveau pareil. et ses amis
qui étaient des cerveaux comme lui, il
disaient "Non, Steven, tu déconnes. Non,
c'est pas vrai. Il y aura encore de la
place pour un milliard d'habitants.
Là, on est 8, on prévoit 11 en 2050.
Donc ça veut dire qu'en 50 ans, il y a
10 milliards de personnes qui vont
disparaître.
[grognement]
Je suis pessimiste. Je suis vraiment
très pessimiste. On y arrivera pas. On a
lâché l'affaire trop. Il y a trop de
gens qui se sentent pas du tout
concernés par cette histoire. Les
histoires de l'eau.
On parle beaucoup de l'eau en ce moment.
Tu te souviens de René Dumont en 74 ?
Toi tu es tu es non, tu es cultivé, tu
es jeune mais tu es cultivé.
[grognement] Euh René Dumont en 74 pour
les élections présidentielles. C'est la
première fois qu'il y avait un candidat
qui se déclarait écologiste. Il a pris
un verre d'eau, il l'a bu en disant "Ce
que je viens de faire, dans quelques
années, on pourra plus le faire." Et
tout le monde s'est foutu de sa gueule.
Au lieu de réfléchir au truc, tout le
monde s'est foutu de sa gueule. Pourquoi
il parle de l'eau ? Aujourd'hui, le plus
grave problème de l'humanité, c'est pas
le manque de pétrole, c'est pas
l'énergie, c'est la flotte. 2 milliards
d'habitants, si je dernière nouvelle ou
1 milliard ou 2 milliards n'ont pas
accès quotidiennement à de l'eau
potable.
Il y a un problème ou pas ? Et bien
aujourd'hui dans notre monde et même moi
même moi je me fais guler, je vis avec
une féministe écologiste.
Elle est adorable mais elle est elle
surveille. Tois tu te laves les dents,
le robinet coule le robinet. Donc
tuarrêtes le robinet, tu dis "Putain, il
y a la scène à côté de la flotte, il y
en a." C'est une réaction crétine que
j'ai.
Elle va en vacances
h
elle prend l'avion, elle a une voiture.
Elle a pas de bagnole. Euh pour les
transports en commun, j'ai pas de
bagnole non plus. de
la viande.
Euh l'avion quand on va quand on promène
Oui, on prend l'avion.
Elle vient, elle mange de la viande. Euh
oui.
Elle utilise du maquillage.
Oui.
Question d'internet. [rires]
Tu viens de te faire tailler un costard,
tu sais pas. C'est de ma faute, j'aurais
pas dû parler de toi.
Question question internet. L'art de la
satire est-il devenu impossible tant
notre monde est devenu ridicule ?
C'est une bonne question.
Question de slot.
C'est une bonne question. C'est-à-dire
que c'est très difficile de rendre
ridicule quelque chose que tout le monde
voit déjà comme étant ridicule.
C'est que le monde porte en lui
aujourd'hui sa propre ironie.
Je le bon exemple de ça et c'est pas
pour en dire du mal, c'est Macron.
il porte en lui sa propre ironie parce
que tout ce qu'il fait qui est de la
pure come tout le temps euh ça se voit
énormément et l'énergie déployée
par ses conseillers par les médias pour
dire "Mais non, c'est pas de la com,
regardez, il est sincère. Cette énergie
déployée prouve au contraire ne fait que
mettre le focus sur le fait que c'est
que ça et que ce qu'il fait est
ridicule." C'est un peu comme le
cryptage sur le sac à main de
Bernadette, ça décuple. Et moi je vois
ça. Alors je sais que peu de gens le
voient. Il y a pas de tout le monde ne
voit pas ça mais tout ce qu'il fait,
toute sa façon d'être, son acting quand
il va à la télé, nous sommes en guerre,
c'est mauvais, c'est posé, c'est pas
sincère, tout est calculé et les
politiques font ça. Et ceux qui sont les
politiques sincères qui se lâchent ou
qui bah il sont prê plein la gueule
parce que quand tu es sincère, tu fais
au bout d'une heure d'entretien, ce qui
peut m'arriver là à tout moment, tu
dérapes. Il y a un moment où ton où ton
ta vigilance baisse, où ton cerveau
feignant,
l'aspect feignant de ton cerveau, on en
a tous un comme ça feignant. Il va au
lieu commun, il va acheter le truc qu'il
faut pas et à ce moment-là, tu en prends
plein la gueule parce qu'il y a que ça
qui sort. Alors évidemment quand tu es
dans le contrôle le plus complet, le
poker face tout le temps, je suis
admiratif
admiratif à l'Assemblée nationale. Il y
en a un qui est extraordinaire avec ça,
c'est Darmanin. Il est là, il bouge pas,
il se fait injurier. Vous avez échangé
des appartements contre des faveurs
sexuelles, vous voulez machin, vous avez
fait c, vous avez fait ça, vous protégez
les flics, vous êtes accusé de viol.
Je ne parle même pas et il répond comme
s'il avait une fiche dans la tête quoi.
Ça me fait flipper cette froideur. Il y
a plus de vivant quoi. C'est pas vivant.
Je préfère Poutou. Poutou. [__]
lui il se lâche quoi. Il y va et tu dis
bah voilà lui il est sincère.
Tu lui confier le feu nucléaire.
Pardon ?
Tu lui confierais le feu nucléaire
à qui ?
À Poutou.
J'en Ouais, j'en sais rien. Le feu
nucléaire. Non, mais c'est une question.
Ouais, je m'attendais pas à cette
question là. Laisse-moi 2 secondes pour
réfléchir. Je regarde Poutou avec un
pull, le [grognement] feu nucléaire. Je
crois que je laisserai même pas Poutou
aller voir Poutine.
Il va se faire bouffer. Tu vas se faire
becter tout cru. Euh,
en même temps, le feu nucléaire, tu
m'arrêtes si je me trompe, c'est pas le
président qui a un bouton qui appuie
dessus. Il y a toute une chaîne non,
c'est pratiquement ça.
Hm.
C'est pratiquement ça.
C'est lui qui a le C'est lui au dernier
moment qui dit "Oui, on appuie."
Il dit il dit hop, on déclenche le feu
nucléaire. Bingo !
Et après, il y a toute une chaîne qui se
met en route avec des codes, des
machins, des bidules. On met les
missiles en route, on le rappelle et on
lui dit "Bon, vous êtes sûr ? On y va
parce qu'il y a plus de monde après. Et
il dit oui, c'est ça.
Je pense que Poutou serait moins fou que
d'autres
et en même temps la dissuasion ça ne
marche que si tu penses que l'autre va
le faire le feu nucléaire. Si tu as un
un fou avec le bouton à la main quand tu
es en face tu dis non lui il va vraiment
appuyer. Je peux pas. Hollande tu dis il
appuiera jamais.
Macron trop raisonnable il appuiera pas.
Je peux lui chier dessus tant que je
veux.
Tu en sais rien Le Pen, j'en sais rien.
Tu as un bon énervé. Moi je Trump il
devait [__] le la panique en face
parce que lui il pouvait à tout moment
dire allez on y va on attaque. W W W
calme-toi, on va détruire la planète là.
Rien à [__]
Et la dissuasion c'est ça. Faut que tu
sois quand même dans le doute, il le
fera ou il le fera pas. L'équilibre de
la terreur c'est ça.
Tu m'autorises à raconter une histoire ?
Oui. Ah ben ça me fait plaisir. Je pense
que tu vas pas le dire. On est en direct
ou pas ?
Bien sûr qu'on est en direct.
Jeis dire, je pense que tu le
rediffuseras pas ce truc là parce que tu
te confies beaucoup je trouve.
C'est Je t'aime bien toi.
Ouais. Sur
sur le feu nucléaire, je discutais avec
feu Jacques Blamont qui était un très
bon ami, quelqu'un qui a beaucoup compté
dans ma vie
et on parlait en fait de de la la
dissuasion nucléaire nord-coréenne.
Ouais. Et le vieux disait Jacques, il
disait "Mais les journalistes, ils sont
juste stupides.
Ils sont tous à dire voilà la Corée du
Nord, elle va taper le Japon." Non, la
Corée du Nord, si elle veut emmerder
tout le monde, elle fait décoller son
missile nucléaire à la verticale.
Elle crame tous les satellites qui a
autour de la Terre avec une seule
pichenette nucléaire et ils retournent
tous à l'âge de pierre.
On se fera peut-être vitrifié mais ça
fera beaucoup de dégâts.
Sur le feu nucléaire quand tu as tu as
le fondateur du programme spatial
français qui t'explique que en 1956, je
parle sous le contrôle de la communauté,
les Américains s'étaient amusés à faire
ça mais à l'époque il y avait six ou h
satellites et ils avaient tous été
cramés à cause de ça. Et ils ont dit,
ils me disaient les journalistes n'y
comprennent rien. Les nord-coréens se
sont dotés de la force nucléaire juste
pour cramer tous les satellites du monde
entier, ce qui est la meilleure des
dissuasion nucléaire. Bon, l'anecdote
est fermée.
Non, non, mais c'est vachement
intéressant.
Question internet. Comment voit-il la
candidature d'un Zemour ?
Mais il sera jamais il a pas de
candidature Zemmour, il parle, c'est son
job. Il parle Bah, il a commun
mais non, ça n'existera pas, je vous le
dis.
Oh là là, il y a des questions.
On va bientôt arriver à la fin de notre
de notre interview. Ça fait je peux
revenir sur tes histoires de satellites
? Vas-y, je t'en prie.
Parce qu'on parle de
guerre. Il y a des gens qui disent faire
révolution armée, les sortir les
fourches et tout ça. Et en fait non, il
faut sortir les ordinateurs en fait.
C'est c'est Ouais. Pourquoi donc
faut sortir les ordinateurs ? parce que
c'est
le feu nucléaire qui pourrait détruire
ces trucs là. D'abord, je pense qu'ils y
arriveraient pas. Ils seraient abattu
avant parce que si toi tu le sais, les
autres le savent. Israël a un dô de fer,
je suppose que les autres en ont un
aussi. Bah les États-Unis, normalement
s'il voi partir des missiles, ils ont de
quoi les dégager. Ça dépend combien, ça
dépend qui les tire. Mais normalement,
si un missile monte à la verticale, au
bout de 2 km, on dit : "J'ai compris la
trajectoire, il va aller là-haut faire
péter les satellites, il dégage." Donc
ça n'arrivera pas. Mais est-ce que alors
je te pose une question puisque votre
communauté, elle est très très branchée
sur le euh sur le hacking et
technologie. Est-ce que on peut imaginer
des révolutionnaires avec une puissance
de calcul suffisante pour déstabiliser
de façon significative des grandes
puissances ? Je parle des États-Unis,
Chine, Russie, France, pourquoi pas ?
Qu'est-ce que tu appelles déstabiliser ?
Foutent le bordel dans leur transport,
[__] leur bordel dans leur
l'approvisionnement d'eau, la gestion
des déchets,
la gestion des déchets.
Le système électrique.
Voilà. système électrique, les barrages
ou
euh couper le transport aérien, on dit
toujours les terroristes sont crétins de
faire sauter des avions. Il suffit que
tu passes un coup de fil, tu laisses un
sac à Adidas au milieu droit si tu te
barres, tu dis il y a une bombe, il
bloque tout pendant 2 heures. Tu as les
avions qui atterrissent plus, ils sont
obligés d'aller à Francfort, du Seldorf,
Bruxelles, Londres. Tu as déjà
déstabilisé avec un sac Adidas. Je je
sais qu'il y avait des des simulations
sur le fait que qu'est-ce qui se passe
si un nœud internet tu le carrefour
si un nœud pétait
qu'est-ce qui se passe sur la surcharge
de la toile
économiquement parlant quelles sont les
répercussions quelle est la résilience
du réseau en cas de ce type d'attaque
mais bon
alors question subsidiaire est-ce que
les terroristes dont on parlait au début
Oui. [grognement]
Euh qui sont des gros méchants, est-ce
qu'ils ont dans leur rang ou est-ce
qu'ils sont en train de former dans leur
rang des gens suffisamment intelligent,
puissant, avec une force des serveurs
suffisamment puissants pour déstabiliser
de cette façon-là, plutôt que de mettre
des avions dans des tours, qui est très
artisanal, de déstabiliser durablement
l'économie d'un pays en faisant un
hacking sur une bourse, en faisant
en déréglant le système d'électricité,
d'évacuation
Enfin tout ce qui nous gêne et tout ce
qu'on fait sans y penser toute la
journée. Tu jettes tes poubelles, tu
sais pas où ça va en fait.
Écoute, à la rentrée,
on fera une émission c'est prévu mais je
suis obligé de la vendre un peu la
mèche. On va traiter de ce type de
question. Je voudrais en profiter pour
remercier Zilot qui est sur le le forum
et qui m'a mis la source et Starfish
Prime. Le
en 1962,
les États-Unis ont fait péter leur
missile nucléaire. D'accord. Starfish et
merciot.
Bah merci, je vais aller regarder ça que
ça m'intéresse.
Est-ce que est-ce que pendant que je te
pose la question,
est-ce que tu as trois bouquins à
conseiller à la communauté ?
Oh [__] ça y est, tu vas me prendre
de cours, j'ai pas pensé à ça. Euh oui,
alors le bouquin
de Alain Accardo, il se trouve sur
internet, il est téléchargeable.
Euh A C A R D O qui s'appelle
socioanalyse analyse du journalisme.
C'est super intéressant pour comprendre
comment euh toutes les chaînes
aujourd'hui qui sont aux mains de
milliardaires, mais ça tout le monde le
sait maintenant pense pareil et pourquoi
les gens qui sont à l'intérieur de ces
chaînes ne se révoltent jamais et ne
sont pas en mesure même de penser à se
révolter contre. à part à la marge pour
certains, mais c'est très rare. Euh là,
la communauté Aidez-moi, c'est le livre
de
ce ce type qui était à l'intérieur du
Bataclan
qui a été oage
euh et qui
le lambeau
c'est pas le lambeau
?
qui s'appelle le un jour dans notre vie,
je crois un truc comme ça. Regardez,
cherchez, trouvez-moi ça. Euh
ce bouquin est extraordinaire
d'humanité, extraordinaire de vérité,
touchant
euh
un jour dans notre vie.
Oui.
de David Fris. David Fritz, c'est ça ?
Oui. C'est extraordinaire, franchement
ce livre, je vous le vous recommande. Et
un tr
Merci Doude.
Hm. C'est doutes qui te qui te qui te
fileent le lentill sèche.
Merci. Euh et un troisème livre,
qu'est-ce que j'ai lu ? Bah [grognement]
parce que je l'aime bien le dernier
Chalum s'appelle Vis dernier Laurent
Chalumau. Ça parle de
machisme de de violence
enfin féministe et comme aujourd'hui on
est dans le vote de cette loi sur les
féminicides, ça ça tombe bien. Voilà.
Si tu avais à laisser un un conseil à
ton petit-fils,
à la jeune génération,
qu'est-ce que tu qu'est-ce que tu
pourrais laisser comme conseil
impérissable sur les réseaux ? Une
bouteille à la mer.
C'est ce qui m'angoisse le plus, je te
jure.
Je les vois les mes petits enfants.
[__] c'est une émotion qui me prend
mais les
quand je vois mes petits enfants, ils
sont magnifiques. Ma fille est une mère
fabuleuse. Son mari est extraordinaire.
Ils vivent bien, ils ont de l'amour
plein et je les vois, ils sont d'une
naïveté, ils se font des câlins, c'est
des jumeaux, ils s'embrassent, ils
chantent et tout ça. Et je les vois, je
leur dis "Les mecs, la planète se
réchauffe et vous vous allez voir la
fin."
Et je regarde ça, je me et ça me ça me
détruit. Ça me détruit. J'aimerais je
sais pas aller voter pour un programme
écologiste qui va prendre ça en compte
quoi. Démerdez-vous. Il y a peut-être
une mini chance en 2022 qui se paste un
truc. Si je me présente, je sais pas, je
sais pas. Il y a peut-être une chance.
Si on rate le coche. Là, c'est fini.
C'est fini. On peut pas se taper
50 d'ultralibéralisme comme sans prendre
en compte aucunement les problèmes
d'eau, les problèmes d'alimentation, de
surpopulation,
de de de pollution des océans avec le
plastique. On peut pas si on ne fait pas
quelque chose là maintenant, mais pas
oui, on va faire, on va non maintenant
des des des milliards, des milliards et
des milliards et des milliards et on va
créer des emplois, on va tous travailler
là-dedans.
Si on fait pas ça ou si on vote pour une
dame qui va fermer des frontières et qui
va
monter une communauté contre une autre,
[grognement]
ça va être le bordel et on va pas aller
à l'essentiel.
Et pour moi, l'essentiel c'est quand
même que si on veut continuer à vivre
sur une planète, il y a encore une
planète. Donc essayer de sauver mes
petits enfants avant 2022, ceux qui ont
le droit de vote parce que quand je
pense à eux, je les vois plutôt dans un
sale état à la fin quoi.
Bruno Gacio, merci,
désolé.
[musique]